microsoft excel is one of the oldest and
most popular spreadsheet application for
data analytics and reporting
hello everyone welcome to this full
course video on data analytics in excel
in this video we will learn everything
from basics to advanced in excel
our experience instructor ajay will help
you learn in detail
you will start off by taking a tour to
welcome to excel where you will learn
the basics
then you will understand the various
crucial functions available in excel
such as vlookup
hlookup sumifs counters if error and
others
you will learn how to sort and filter
data in excel then
we'll focus on conditional formatting
and data validation
moving further you will get an idea how
to create pivot tables in pure charts in
excel
and finally you will see how to use the
data analysis toolpak to perform various
data analysis operations such as
regression sampling descriptive
statistics and much more
over to ajay now hi everyone welcome to
this
tutorial on microsoft excel so
we will learn about functions and
formulas we will learn about conditional
formatting
data validation pivot chart and pivot
table
now let's look at a scenario here so
one day in a startup
one professional speaks that their
business is growing
and they would need an efficient way to
work with
the data they would have to find a way
to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague responds
well we can make use of microsoft excel
to do this job the question is
will excel be able to cater to their
business
needs now the colleague responds
well we can make use of excel in several
ways
and it also is a cost efficient
option now in that case
the colleague who posed the question
says let's go ahead with excellent
let's train our employees in excel
and the suggestion is welcomed
which would make the job easier for them
and they would basically decide on using
excel so they decide on taking a
training right away
and basically starting to learn excel
now before we move to excel
one of the question is why should we use
excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so excel
proves to be a great platform to perform
various mathematical calculation
on large data sets which is one of the
biggest requirements
of various organizations these days
various features in excel like searching
sorting
filtering makes it easier for you to
play with the data
and excel also allows you to beautify
your data and
present it in the form of charts tables
and data bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting
and analysis can be performed with the
help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and
goal planning worksheets excel also
provides good security for your data
excel files have the feature of password
protection
this way your information can be safe
now when we talk about what is excel and
how it can be used
so excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet
can be basically used for a lot of
different tasks
than just storing the information in
so called tabular format
now microsoft excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data
it is in the form of a spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas
used in excel and before we do that we
can also
quickly take a small tour to understand
how to work with excel now to do that
what we can do
is we can type in in our search
say for example excel and just select
your excel app which is installed
and here you see you have a lot of
options which says
take a tour drop down list get started
with formulas
make your pivot table going forward with
pie charts and much more
so we can click on this one which says
take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says
welcome to excel and if
you have always wanted to be better at
excel
you have this which can help you so
let's click on create
and that takes us to the store window
now that says
instructions for screen readers which
basically
talks about 10 different steps in which
we can learn
excel and using the spreadsheet app
so there are more than 11 sheets
which we see here at the bottom end and
each one
gives us a simple example which we can
work on
so for example if i click on add
now that takes me to this page which
says how do we add numbers
now you might be provided data which we
can
upload by loading a file from our
machine or getting data from a web
source or even connecting to a database
so there are various options which we
will see
in some time so here we have an option
which is called data you can click on
this one
and this basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some
you can always click on from other
sources
and you can get your data from sql
server from analysis services
from odata data feed you can get in from
xml from data connection wizard
or also from microsoft query you can be
running in different queries here which
shows up in the option which says new
query
there are connections which you can use
and that basically will display all the
connections
for this particular workbook which we
did not have as of now but we can create
them
but let's look at simple examples now
you can follow these instructions here
which says basically adding up the
numbers
and that could be easily done by just
placing your cursor here
and what you could do is either you can
type in the formula
that is from which row to which
row you would want to add the data so
for example i could just do
a sum here and that shows up all the
different functions
which are available then we can open up
a parenthesis
and we can say i would be interested in
totaling the amount
from column d and i would select
for example d4 so
i could be doing this and then i could
say d4
onwards till d7 so that's the
data which i'm interested in you can
close your parenthesis and hit enter
and that gives you the total there is
also a shortcut for this
which you can always do is we can first
delete this
and you can just place your cursor here
and just use your alt and equals
that automatically selects the
numericals
which we can anytime expand or
basically collapse so i will basically
select this which says this function
needs two numbers which is number one
and number two
and then you can hit on enter and that
gives you the total
so similarly we can be getting in the
data
here by selecting all the fields so
here it also says that you can use a
shortcut now
what we can also do is we can add
numbers over 50
by selecting the yellow cell here
and then giving a condition such as
so i can basically use something like
sum if
and then open a parenthesis i can select
i would be interested in this row and
then
i can even drag and drop till here so
that
tells me d11 to d15 you can then put in
a comma here
and you can give your condition say for
example we would say i would be
interested
in numbers only above 50
and we can select this close your quotes
and then just close your paranthesis
and that's your formula so you can do
this and that basically gives me the
total is hundred
now similarly we could do that for the
amount here
i could select this now there is also an
option i can click on home
and i can go for something like auto sum
so that's one more way
of doing it which anyway says sum is
alt plus equals so it automatically adds
up your values and i can try doing an
auto
sum that automatically selects my rows
and then i can get my total now as per
this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula
here but add amounts that are less than
100
and the result should be 160. so what we
can do
is we can basically select all the
numbers which are
lesser than 100 so the way we did
earlier here there can be always a
shortcut so you can
always for example if you would want to
avoid typing in the formula you can
always copy it from here
and then just hit on enter
so you are back into this cell and then
i can basically go
here and paste the number and then
as per the requirement we are required
to select
anything which is lesser than 100 so
what i could do
is i could select here i could say let's
say
g and then i can change this value to
g15
and that's one more way now we see our
selected
rows have been changed so i can hit on
enter and i can check what is the result
so
we would be interested in looking for
numbers which are
lesser than 100 so i will have to also
change this one
to a lesser sign and that basically
gives me
the total which is 160 so that's how you
can simply
add numbers you can use autosum you can
type in the formula
you can select the fields or you can
just place your cursor where you would
be looking for
a sum and then you can just do a alt
equals and that basically
populates the sum
now let's look at some easy options of
filling your cells or automatically
populating the values
in your cells within your excel sheet
now here we have an option with says 100
now we can click on this and that
basically
says it is making a sum of
column c4 to d4
so if i click on this one i can check
that this is
row number 4 which shows up here
and i also know this is column c
i also have d so this equals is
basically giving me
a sum of c4 to d4 now what we can do is
we can always place our cursor here
at the right corner and then we can just
drag and drop and this basically
gives me a total of all the numbers for
all different rows so this is one
shortcut which we can do
to get the total excel will
automatically give the totals which we
call
as filling down now what we can do
is in the same way if we would want to
get the totals here
we can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me it is c 11 to c
14 total so it is totaling the rows
from c11 so column c and 11th row
till 14th row and that's the sum now
what i can also do is
i can similarly like above we can
do a filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here
and then just dragging and dropping it
all the way where you would need the
totals
and this basically gives me the total
there is one more quick way to check
if this is right so the easiest option
would be
to select this cell now what i can also
do is i can just
select all of these fields by just
highlighting and selecting all the
fields once it is selected
press on control r and that gives you
the total
now if we would be doing this top down
then i could select
all these rows for this particular
column
and then i could do a ctrl d so that's
your
filling down and this one was filling
right
so this is an easier option of doing a
fill
when you would want to have the formula
applied to every row
as it occurs in the first row or the
last row we could test this by for
example selecting these fields
i could delete them and i have here
which says 130
i could just place my cursor here and i
could drag it all the way up
and that should also do the same magic
which we were seeing from
top down so this is a simple way wherein
you can fill up your
cells and you can also automatically
propagate or move your computation
to all the cells let's
look at the split option which basically
helps us in splitting the data when we
have some kind of pattern or when we
have some kind of delimiters in our data
in say one particular column and we
would want to derive the values out of
it
so we can always use the splitting
option
now the easiest option would be so for
example we have our email column which
has the email ids and which
we can clearly see has a first name dot
last name now i see that there is a last
name smith
filled up here first name is empty so
what i can also do
is i can just type in say nancy
here now that's the first name i can
again start typing the second name and
as soon as you do that
you would see a faded list of numbers
and that's your clue to hit enter
and once you do that you would see all
the first
names have been filled in here if you
would want to maintain the case
sensitiveness
you can just go ahead and delete these
and let's type in as it occurs so let's
say
nancy as the first name go down to the
next cell
and just type in andy and there is your
grade
list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name
what we can also do is we can
just select this particular field and
either we can type in control
e which basically fills up all the
options
now i can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking control z
and that's basically gone what i can
also do
is i can select a particular field and
then
i can go into home option and under home
you should have an option here which
says fill so you can select this
and then you can do a flash fill which
is what we are doing here so click on
flash fill and that automatically fills
up the values
so in this way you can work within your
spreadsheet
and you can be filling up the values
where a delimiter by default is
understood
and we can split the data now however
sometimes you might have some data which
has a different kind of delimiter
and there is again a smarter way of
splitting your data
so you can always scroll down here and
that says splitting a column based on
delimiters
so we have some values in the data
column and
these values in each row are separated
by comma
so select this your data is already
selected text to
columns delimited comma is selected
and now click on next so it basically
says
what is the destination let's select
this one
and i can choose what would you want to
have so that shows me this would be my
data preview
now i can basically select this one
i can say finish and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in
in the columns appropriately so this is
how you can split your data based on a
delimiter
and then organize your data in a better
way now there are some advanced options
which we can learn later but this
basically tells about
using a formula so this is something if
say
if we have some name in one cell and if
you would want to split it into
first name your helper column
your middle name last name so that can
also be done
using formulas and this basically tells
how would you extract characters from
your left
cell and how would you place them in
your right cell so you can try this
activity
which is a little more of advanced
option the benefit
is that you can always use this
wherein if you do some kind of
transformation using your formulas
if your original data gets updated then
the split data will also
get updated and that's the benefit of
using
formulas where you can place values from
one cell into multiple cells based on
execution of your details in the
formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows
and that's where transposing comes into
picture it might be useful when you have
your data
in your x and y axis or as i would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows
to become the columns and columns to
become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can
select all your values
so here we basically have six columns
and i would say two rows
now i can select all of these and then i
can select an empty
field for example the one which is
highlighted here
well you can always do a ctrl alt v
that's a shortcut
what you can also do is once you have
selected all your fields
you can just copy them so just do a ctrl
c
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do
is you can do a special paste or paste
special so
under your home you have the paste
option and here you can go for paste
special
and once you do that you need to select
the transpose
option over here and click on ok and now
you will see that the columns and the
rows have been transposed
so your row name was item and that has
become the column heading
you had row name as amount and that has
become the column heading
and all your values have been transposed
in this particular format now there is
another way of doing that
and again that's using your formulas so
what you can do
is you can transpose with a formula also
and that basically works
when you have similar kind of data so
this has six columns
and basically two rows so you can
basically
do this so you can select this and
earlier
we were doing a copy but now what we
would want to do is we would want to
just look at the row numbers
which tells me it is c33c34
and it starts with c and ends in with
your h
column so what we can do is we know
that we have six columns and two rows so
transposing that would actually give me
two
columns and six rows so what we can do
is we can
select two columns and
six rows in our excel sheet i can
then basically start typing in the
message or i can just go to the address
bar
and here i can say
transpose let's go for c33
h34 it basically selects my data
and now i can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see
all the values have been populated now
you can
just place your cursor in one of the
cells but if you see the
address bar the formula remains the same
this is because this is an array formula
so we can read more about an array
formula here
it's basically something which performs
calculations and
on more than one cell in an array and
in the example here the array is the
original data that is c33
to h34 so your transpose is just
changing
the horizontal orientation to the
vertical orientation
so this is a very simple way in which
you can
basically use the excel's capability to
transpose your data
and convert your rows into columns and
columns
into rows apart from
working on additions
subtractions filling up your data
sorting
the data or basically splitting your
data
transposing your data one of the other
requirements is sorting
and filtering your data now that can be
very handy when you're working on huge
data
and you would want to sort it in a
particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field
or if that field was or if the cell was
highlighted with a particular color
sorting the data so let's look at how
excel can be used for sorting and
filtering examples are pretty simple
here
so let's check that so if we're going to
sort and filter and say this is the data
i have
say for example i would want to sort the
values in the department column
alphabetically so what i can do is i can
select
department column and i'm already in the
home
tab i can straight away go here which
says sort and filter
i can then say sort a to z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department
column and once once i do this you would
see the data has been sorted
but it's not just this data we can just
do a control z
and check what are the values we have so
here we have meat
which is beef and 90 ten thousand
the values then you have bakery which
should ideally be the first
row if we sort it in alphabetical order
which goes with bakery as deserts
you have the values so we can check this
again so select department
and then just with sort and filter and
let's say sort a to z
and if you see the data has changed but
it's not just in changing your first
column but then
it has taken care of all the data
however the data has been
sorted based on the department column so
you have bakery
which aligns with deserts which has the
values and now we have
all the data which has been filtered now
what we can also do is
we can sort december's amounts from
largest
to smallest so what we can do is
we can basically click any cell in the
december column
let's say 20 000 and then what i can do
is i can go into sort filter
and then i can say sort largest to
smallest
so if you see bakery breads is the row
which has the smallest data
or maybe you have delhi sandwiches
so that one looks also smaller so let's
do
a larger to smallest and if i do this
you would see the values have been
shifted now
so it is no more based on the department
column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values
in the december column and you see
bakery
which was alphabetically the first one
has become
second last so either you can sort the
data based on a department column
which goes based on the values these are
all string values or words
so it sorts alphabetically if you have
numbers might be you can give some
values and you can
sort the data you could anytime
do a custom sort and you could basically
select if you would want to select the
data so i could do a custom
sort and then i could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting
what is the sorting needs to be done is
it cell values is it
cell color font color conditional
formatting
and then you can also choose the order
so that's one more way to do that
now if you scroll down that also shows
how you can sort by date
or a color so for example if you would
want to sort
based on the expense date so there are
different options
so what i can do is i can select this
date field i can just do a right click i
can go into sort
and then i can choose i would want to
sort
oldest to newest so since i selected the
date field
it basically has sorted all the data and
it has taken the expense date into
consideration
now there are these filters which you
see on the row headings
we could have also used those so i could
have selected this
and that basically says or mentions
which
are the dates i would be interested in
looking at i
also have sort by color here i can do a
sort oldest to newest or newest to
oldest so i could
also use these filters which have been
applied here
now we have the data which is in color
so
if i would want to basically select
the color columns or color cells i could
select this
i can basically do a right click here
and when i go into sort
i could choose put selected color or
cell
color on the top and that basically will
make sure that my data is sorted
and it has also sorted that in a
descending order
so in this way you can sort or basically
filter your data
what we can also do is we can add
filters so sometimes
we can go for formulas which we would
want to use
what we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here
now how does the filter come in there so
if i would select
a particular row i could select a
particular row
and then i could decide if i would want
to just add a filter to this one
and that's how the filter has come in so
we have the filter
what we can do is we can basically click
on this drop down
and then you have something like number
filters
so we can always go here we can
basically choose one of these
so we can basically choose above average
so i could select this and then
basically it shows me the values
we could also delete the filter by
clicking on this one
and we could say well i'm not interested
in this filter anymore
so i could clear the filter and that
shows me all the values
or i could say that
let's click on some other field for
example
food i can go in here i can go into
number
filters and then i could say well i'm
interested
in values which are below average
above average might be greater than and
then i can
choose what is the value so for example
if we say i am interested in
food which is greater than 25 dollars
i could give a value here i could say ok
and now i have applied the filter
similarly
you can select this and then you can
just clear your filter and your data is
back
so remember no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically
based on the filter not shown so that's
good enough
for us and in this way you can sort and
filter
the data so for more details obviously
in all the
sheets you have the links which point to
more information on the web
and you can always refer to these so
this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data
which has been stored within your excel
within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering
it will also be good to learn how to
work with tables
or basically converting your data into a
tabular format
and then doing some easy computations so
click on this tables option here
now here we see there is some data which
is in five columns and n number of rows
so i can basically select this data
and then what i can do is i can insert
choose the table option and then it says
my table as headers and we'll be okay
with that
i'll say okay and now if you see this is
the table created
it basically has different filters which
we have learnt earlier how to use
and this is basically my table which is
a collection of cells which has some
special features
so we can easily add rows to this table
we can add columns to this table and we
can even do some calculations
so for example here i can click on this
one
i can basically enter some
field and then i can hit on enter and we
see that this row has been
inserted wherein we can easily fill in
values for example i would say
chocolates i could give some value
here size 25 000 might be 35 000
and then basically i can given some
values here
now what you can also do is you can
continue
adding rows in this way and
say for example you would want more
columns
so you can select this option here
in the top bottom right corner you can
just
drag it towards the right and that
basically has
automatically created columns for my
next
month wherein i can feed in the data
so this is a simpler way wherein you can
keep
adding more rows and columns to your
data if that has been converted in a
tabular format
now let me just do a ctrl z that
basically deletes the columns
again ctrl z deletes the last row which
we added
and i can stop here or i can even remove
my values by
doing multiple control z and removing my
rows so this is how i converted
my data into a table and then i can
easily work on this
what i can also do is i can do some
calculations
so what we can do we have a table here
we have a total field and what we can do
is we can just select one cell here now
as we have learned earlier
we can do a alt and then equals
and that basically says what
is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum
of the last three months and if that's
what you would want to do just hit on
enter and it has automatically
calculated
the totals for all your rows
for these three columns so the sum
formula
is getting filled up now i can select
any particular cell
and i can look in my address bar so it
has already given me the formula
where it has started calculating the
sum from the october column till
the december column and has given me the
calculated values
of the columns what we can also do is we
can get total rows
in the table now that's a simpler option
so what we can do is we can select any
cell
in this particular table and then
we see that there is a table tools
design option showing up here
now i can select this and then it says
well let's get a total row so let's
select this
and it automatically populates the total
here
and if you would want the average then
we could select this
and from the drop down i can select what
i'm interested
in so for example i would want the
average values and not the
total i could just select this and that
gives me
the average of these values so we can
always do simpler computations here
by converting our data into table format
let's learn about one more efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs
so let's see how drop downs work here
now say for example you have this data
which has the values in the food column
and department is empty and say for
example you would want to
enter the values in department however
you would want to select
the department should either have
produce or
meat and bakery and these are the only
three options which
should be available for any user to fill
in the values
how do we do that so we can basically
create a table by pressing ctrl d
so what i can do is under my department
here i can select one of the cells and
then i can do a control t
that basically converts this into a
table i can say okay
and my table is created now what i can
do
is once this part is done
we can select all the blank fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable
now under your data tab you can go in
and select data validation and this has
an option called data validation
click on this which basically says allow
any value
so here i will select i would want to
give a list of values
and then i can type in my values here
which i can say produce
say for example meat and then say
bakery now these are the values so we
can click on
ok and once we have done that
we basically have a drop down here next
to
apples which will only show us the
values which we can
feed in under the department column so i
can go into every cell
and then i can basically choose what is
the department which handles this
and then basically i can select one of
these from the
drop down so this is an easier option
of creating your drop down and then
feeding in the values
from the set of values which you have
defined here
on the right so this is a simple example
of using your drop downs
working with your tables working with
your sort and filter
transpose split filling up your data
adding in some data here and similarly
you can use
excel for more than one use case
using its inbuilt features to easily
work
with your data let's see how we can
import data or bring in data into our
excel from your local machine
or from an external web source
so what we can do is we can open up a
blank excel sheet
and say for example you have been
provided
a text file or a csv file
and you would want to import that data
into your excel sheet
that can be easily done so right now
i've opened an
excel sheet now i can click on data and
here i have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources so or you can click on
connections if you have already created
some
so we can click on from other sources
so this is one option where you can
connect to your different data sources
and you can get the data from
one of these what we can also do is i
can click on connections
now it says there is none i can click on
add
it says well show the connections where
connection
files on network connection files on
this computer
so i can say let's get some files from
this computer
now if that does not show up something
so say browse for
more and that basically shows you
different options so let's
basically select a folder where i have
some data sets i'll click in here
and this is basically a folder where i
have some data sets
now let me select this particular file
and i know it is a csv
file so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have
gone and looked into the properties of
the file and it says it is a dot csv
file
which is what we are interested in so
i'll take this file
i'll say open now this basically shows
me
the text import wizard option which says
is the file delimited
i'll say yes click on next so i will
select comma
as my delimiter i can say text qualifier
is none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me
the data is what is the data in the csv
file you can click on next and then
you have an option which says data
format is general
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options
so i'll just say finish and basically
now this has been created here
so we basically have this and now i can
click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections
it shows me the data which we have here
the connection which we have created say
open and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on ok
and now this data is automatically
inserted in my excel file i can
basically
save it into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get
some other data from web so what i can
do
is i can go into my github and let's say
i would be interested in this csv file
so i can select this and this is my
github path
a path on web so i can click on draw
and that basically gives me the raw path
where this particular file is now you
can select this
copy this particular path and here
you can come back to your excel sheet we
would be interested in getting the data
from web
might be from a text file where we will
have to specify the delimiters
or let's go to web and here i can given
the web
path from where i would be interested in
getting the file
let's give the github path which is
publicly available
and then click on import now once you
click on import
it tells me there are two fields data
and value
these are within double quotes
separated by comma so first let's click
on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from
web and put in here it says existing
worksheet so we had already created a
new worksheet
so let's click on ok and now you have
the data coming in
but then this basically shows me in one
particular field so what we can also do
is we can just do a control a
that selects all my columns here and
that's my data
so we can then basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next
we can select comma and let the text
qualifier be
quotes it shows me data
preview click on next so you have
the general format it shows the
destination that's the column
click on finish and now your data has
been split
and you have the data which you have
imported from web so this
is the data which is coming in from web
this is the data which came in from my
local machine
and similarly we can even create
connection with an existing database
so i can basically click on connections
if i would want to do that so i have an
option called connection here
and it says where the selected
connections are used
i can basically click on add i can
basically
choose if i would want to get the files
from network
or from computer like we did earlier i
can click on browse for
more which should show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new
sql server connection you can connect to
a new data source coming in from
different place
you could basically choose what kind of
connection you would you want
so these are all the different options
which we can go for
and we can basically connect to a
database for example
if i have some database and say for
example
access database i can see
if there are some files with that
particular database and i can
import it so similarly we can
also uh click in here which says new
query
and that also gives you an option of
getting the data from your files
from all these folders from databases
so you can basically click here and then
you can
import data from a mysql database
provided
that is set up on your local machine or
on a particular server
you can go from cloud you can get it
from online services
you can get it from other sources which
says from web
from your hadoop file system from active
directory
from a blank query and you can even
combine queries
wherein you can run a power query editor
you can get the data from different
sources and then you can bring it into
your
excel so in this way you can get your
data from
different sources into your excel into
your spreadsheet
and then you can continue working on
those data sets
we have already learned some basic
operations which you can do in excel
and let's implement our knowledge
by working on this particular data which
is
coming in from housing data set now here
if we see some fields we have
agent date listed area list price and
this is basically the data which has
been
sorted in newest to oldest order of date
listed so how do we
arrive at this so what i can do is
i can just click on data listed and then
i can either go in here
i can select sort i can get into custom
sort
and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to sort the
data so i would look for the newest data
to the oldest data that means that would
be in a descending order of dates
or you could say the oldest date or the
earliest month will be towards the lower
side of your sheet
so here we can select date listed now i
can say let it sort
based on cell values and the order what
we
have here so we have newest to oldest so
let's select this
i can say okay and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that
seems to be the latest date and as we go
down we will see
an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in this date
listed so we have sorted
our data into newest to oldest order
and that's based on your date column so
the result shows up
here now what we can also do is we can
have
different questions which we would want
to answer so for example i would want to
sort the data in
ascending order of area and descending
order of
agent name how do we do that so let's
look into this
so this is here i already have the
result here and
how did i get this so i am looking for
ascending order of
area in descending order of agent name
so we can
start with any particular column that
does not matter
so for example if i look into this excel
sheet
i have my agent name select this which
we want in a descending order
so we could either do a sort and then go
for
descending sort z to a we could also
use the filter option here on the top
right
and we could do it or i could just say
sort z
to a and then it has arranged
the data based on the agent column being
in descending order
now i can go into area and then i can
again do a sort and i wanted my area
column
to be used for sorting the data
ascending to descending
and that basically not only changes the
order of this particular column but
for my complete data so let's do that
and now if you see
we have the data which has been sorted
so we can see how many values we have
here
and the area values which we see and
this is how you get your
result so i'll just do a ctrl z
and again and i'm back to my original
data
and this is the sorted result which we
are seeing at
similarly we can answer other questions
for example sort the data according to
the following
order of area that is
we are saying county central
and then your county so we can basically
choose
in which particular way we would want to
do it so it is county
central and then again county so
if i look into my sheet 3 so here
i basically have my data which is having
some south county
then you have your central and then you
have your
north county so we would want to sort
the data to solve our problem
which is according to the following
order
so first we go for area then we go for
south county
central and north county so what we can
do
is we can basically have area field
selected
and i would want to sort this particular
data
so i have south county central
and north county so i can basically go
for
custom sort and then i can choose which
is the value
or column which i am interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like
cell values well you can also try to
explore conditional formatting icon
if this is what you would want to use or
we can basically go for just cell values
and here we can say if i would be
interested in first getting my values
for
south county so for example i can say
custom list
and then i can basically given the new
list here
so i can say s dot
county and then i would want
central and then i would want north
county so let's select this
as it exists we can basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay
and then say okay here and now what we
would want is
we would want our data so we can compare
that
with the values which we see here it
starts with kelly
you have in the 12th row something like
lang and that's what we are doing
so we can basically arrange the data in
a particular order
by choosing a custom list and then
sorting your
data so that's one more simpler task
of what we have done where we have
sorted the data
in the order where under our area column
we first wanted south county then we
wanted
central data and then we wanted north
county
so this is how you can do it now
let's look into one more problems it
says find all the houses
in the central area and we would want to
basically apply a regular filter let's
let's see how do we do that
so we can click on this and here we have
the data
so the problem statement is we would
want to find
all the houses in central area
now how do we do that we can do a
sorting but
we would want to use the filter which
you see here
is implemented so how do you do it so
you can select this
area and say for example i would want to
apply
filter i can just go in here and i can
say let's get a filter
on my first row and now i have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the central area houses
let's go in here it says all these
fields are selected that means it shows
everything wherein your area has all
these values
let's unselect this and then i will only
be
interested in the central so let's say
okay
and then say okay so now you see
that the area filter has been applied
and we are looking at the central column
so
what we have done is we have applied a
simple filter
and we are looking at our data at any
point of time if you do
not want the filter
then what i can do is i can select this
and i can say well i'm interested in all
the data
so i could do this or you can clear the
filters from
area and you get your data back so
that's in one way you can filter out
your data
so let's look at an example of sort and
filter
where we might have to filter the data
based on two columns
or multiple columns with different kind
of values where it could be and
and or condition now say for example
this is the data i have
and this is the question which we need
to answer such as
find the list of all houses in the
central region
with pool and south county without pool
now if it was a simple filter based on
one cell
i could have just selected my
header row i could have then
applied the filter
and once i have the filter i can look in
area where i have three
regions so i'm only interested in
central and south county so i can get
rid of north county and that's fine
but then we have two different
conditions here so we need
the data in central region
to have the value for pool being true
and for south county the value has to be
without pool now how do we
do that so what we can do is we can
first
create a copy of these headers
here so let me do that now the
area has to be south county
so basically i can either just select
this
and i can choose this value
and then i can select this and then i
can choose
central so that's the criteria which i
have
and the pool value has to be so
central region should be with pool
so then this one basically has to be
true and this one
has to be basically false so south
county is without pool
so let's select one of the values here
and this is my criteria
now to get my result uh we can always
place your cursor here
and you can check this is m column and
eighth row okay so we would want the
result here so let's go ahead and now
click on data
and then in filter you have an option
called advanced
and here what i can do is i can say i
would want to filter the list
in the place but that's not what i would
want to do so i'll say copy to another
location
and here if you see the list range will
tell me
that this is the data so a1 to j126 so a
to j column selected and all the rows
criteria range is basically based on
what i have given here so that is
m from 1
to v which is 3
so i am selecting these columns and then
i am saying
all the way whatever criteria i have
given and copy
2 i am saying m8
to v8 so that basically will give me
my filtered result so you could
basically just say
okay and now i have my data which has
been filtered
and i have my area which is south county
that is without pool central with pool
again south county without pool and then
if you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied
where simply we have filtered the data
based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way you can have your customized
filter applied on two different columns
and get your data
which can be either replacing the
existing content
or in the same sheet in different set of
columns and rows
you can have your result let's look at
one more
example of filtering where you are
trying to filter the data based on an
and condition
condition being met in two different
columns and then you would want to
filter out the data for only specific
columns so the situation is the agents
with a house in north
county that should be county area having
two and a single type family so we are
talking about two
bedrooms and we would
basically have a single type family and
here the criteria
is that we would want to only
populate these columns which is agent
area
bedroom and type now what you can do is
as i explained earlier
that you can get your result in the same
sheet in a different location
so here i have created these headers
which says agent
area bedrooms and type now this is
basically
a copy of all the columns what we have
here
agent data listed area list price
bedrooms
bath square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here
and this is where we will give our
advanced criteria to filter the data
so the conditions which need to be met
is we need to look at
north county so for example here
in area i can basically go ahead and
select one of the values
north county now the criteria is having
two bedrooms only so let's say bedrooms
and let's say the value should be two
and then basically
i am saying a single type family so when
you would want
the single type family so here under
type
i can give the criteria single type
so this is my and condition so we are
saying north county area
having two bedrooms and the type is
single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if i select this
this one tells me that this is m
one row onwards till v
two so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this
so let's go ahead and then go for data
filter advanced and here in advanced
it says filter the list in place now
that's not what we would want to do so
i'll say copy to another location
this basically selects the list range so
which is telling me
a1 to j126
so that's the columns and rows selected
criteria range is based on
m1 v2 which we have given here
and copy 2 i would say for example from
m7 to p7
now this is the area where i would this
is the place where i want the result
let's say okay and now i get my data
which is based on the question which has
been asked
that you would want the agents with a
house in north county area
having two bedrooms and single type
family so in this way
you can basically do advanced filtering
get your data and get it stored in the
sheet anywhere
at a different location well i could
have also
done filtering in place and that would
have replaced
the data which we have but that's not
what we want we would want the filtered
result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some
advanced filtering we can also use excel
to
filter out the data in one particular
column
which might be conditional or say
using some numerical filters now here
say for example the problem statement is
that you would want to display all the
houses whose list price is between
45 000 to 600 000
or say for example we would want to
filter out the data to
something else say for example let's say
i have
i would want to filter out the data
between 300
000 and 400 000 so we can
basically update this
say for example i am saying i am
interested in 300
000 to
400 000 and that's the criteria to
filter out the data now there are two
different ways so there are two
easier ways to do it one is i would want
to
look at the list price so i can select
this
i can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy
you can click on this one and then you
can go into number filters
and you can choose between now that's
one easier way of doing it
so i could basically select this i could
say
i'm looking for value which is greater
than or equal to 300
000 and then is less than
or equal to 400 000 so if i
just do this i have applied my filter
and i have my data which is filtered
based on my
criteria right so that's one easier way
of doing it
or let me do a control z
now let the filter be there which you
can
anyways use but what we can also do is
as we have seen earlier methods so get a
set or get your column headers here
and then you are giving two columns here
now the only difference between my
this set of columns which i have 1 2 3 4
and then you have 7 and 10 columns and
if you see
here we have 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right
so whenever you want a and condition you
will basically
add the columns where i can give add
condition if it is the same column
if it was a different column then it
would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie
in the same line and all condition would
lie in a different line
now here i can give this value so i am
looking for
listed price being between 300
000 so i am saying it should be greater
than or
equal to 300
000 and then i can say less than or
equal to 400 000 now that's my criteria
and then i need my result here which is
in
m7 so what i can do is
once i have given my criteria which i'll
be using
to filter i can get into data i can get
into
advanced and then i can say copy to
another location
so it is selecting my a1 to j126
criteria range is based on m1 to
w 2 and then i would want my result
from this particular column so let's say
okay
and now you have your data filtered out
in a different location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition
so you can filter out the data in this
way or
you could just apply a filter on a
column and give the
conditions now let's solve one more
interesting problem
and here we would want to use excel
where we would have an
and and an or condition so say for
example this is the data given to you
and the question is that you would want
to find all the houses
in north county again that's a spelling
mistake but then the
north county area with a list price
greater than 300
000 and having three or four bedrooms so
the bedroom
has conditional so it has or three and
four
and then basically you have list price
which is greater than 300
000 now i could have obviously selected
the columns
and then basically gone for a
filter so i can just do a filtering
here and then i'm looking for list price
being greater than 300
000 so which we can always give a number
filter
and i can say greater than and then
i can say greater than or equal
so i can say greater than and then i can
give three thousand
thirty three hundred thousand and that's
basically the filter
which we would want and here
i would want to select the bedrooms
which should be
just either three or four so
if for example here i go in here and i
unselect this and then i say three and
four
right so i am getting my data which is
greater than 300
000 and it should have the bettering
values which will be
either three or four selected now that's
one way of doing it
let's do a control z and get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear
filter so you get your data back as it
was
so what we can do is we can here
give the criteria so for example i have
my list price now this is what
i would want as a condition so let's say
greater than 300 000
300 and bedrooms should be
three and then i can say greater
than three hundred thousand
and then i can say four so this one
basically gives me
a situation where your list price has to
be greater than 300 000
and bedroom should be either three or
four so we have given our filtering
criteria
now to get the result what we can do is
we can go into data
we can go into advanced and we can say
copy to another location
so our list range is selected which is
columns a to j row number 1 to 126
your criteria range is given in m1 to v3
where we have specified and we are
saying the result would be in
m7 to v7 so if i do this
now i have got the same data which we
were seeing earlier
and here the bedroom values are 3 or 4
and basically the list price is greater
than 300
000 so this is a simpler way in which
you can
create your filters and all this
advanced filtering what we are seeing
it will be saved with your sheet you can
always go back
and change this value or you could do
filtering where one person has to look
into the filter to see
what values have been selected
now that we have looked into some
operations which we can perform in excel
using
filter or sorting the data creating your
tables let's also
quickly look at functions and formulas
which can be used
for doing some easy calculations or
computations
now excel can be used in different kind
of data analysis
so for example you have different
inbuilt functions which can be used
and we can always check for a particular
function so for example if i
had if i wanted to look at a particular
function
i could just type in here
something for example is and then it
shows me
all the possible functions and you can
always have a look
at the detail of the function for
example you have is
even which will return true if the
number
is even if we would say is logical
so i could search for is logical
and that tells me whether a value is
logical value true or false and returns
your value
true and false now we can
obviously say subtotal so you can search
for
any of these useful functions and that
tells me
what this function can be used for so
returns a subtotal in a list or
a database you have many other such
functions such as
integer sum average you may be
interested in working on truncating
some data getting the absolute value
getting the square root
basically getting a count or getting a
max
value you can look for any particular
functions within your excel sheet
now you also have other functions such
as
now or time for example let's look at
now function so i can search for
now and here it is
so this is returns the current date and
time formatted as a date and
time so this is the function which we
would want to use
and if i just give the function
it tells me what is the current time
let's first look at the description of
time
here so say for example i would want
time it says converts hours minutes and
seconds given as numbers
to an excel serial number formatted with
a time format
so for example if i would say 2
hours and then 30 minutes
and 30 seconds and if i do this
it has basically converted this into
your time format
so you can always use different inbuilt
functions
for your work now we will also look at
some advanced functions like sum f
or sum ifs you have count f and count
f's and you can be working on various
functionalities
of excel to easily help you in doing
some calculations
computations working with your data
working with your
different cell values so let's look at
some example of using functions like sum
or sum if so for that
let's go to this sheet and here we have
some data
now i have already applied a filter
which can allow me to filter out the
data
so it says find the total units that
were
sold in the east region now we know
that in region we have east
and i have multiple regions i could
basically be saying unselect
all and select only east and say ok
and that basically gives me the units
which were sold and if i place my cursor
here
and then if i did a auto sum
so it would basically give me the
function which is being used so
something like subtotal
and it is basically working on
your rows which is e2 to e44
and here we can just do this
so that gives me the total but this is
this is
fine you could do that but
it would be good if we know how do we
use a function like sum if to do that
so here i'm seeing this is the subtotal
where i'm looking at the values and
basically what i have done is i have
filtered out the region
and then basically i am getting a count
but this does not give me clearly how
a sum was calculated from all the values
which were listed
what we can also do is let's do a
control z and let's get it back
so now we have our data and we would
want to get the
total units that were sold in the east
region so what i can do
is i can start typing in my formula
and for that i'll use a inbuilt function
so for example i would be interested in
going for sumif
now it says sumif adds the cells
specified by a given
condition or criteria when you talk
about some
ifs this is when you could give set of
conditions
or multiple criteria so let's look at
some if
let's do this now obviously this gives
me an error because the
formula is not right so we have to
basically come in here
and let's start with sum if now
when i say sum if it shows me there is a
function with
sumif which we would want to use and
here
once i open up the bracket it tells me
okay what is the range
of data which you are interested in so i
am interested
in all the units that were sold in the
east
region so we are interested in the
region
which is here so i can basically be
selecting this and this tells me
you are interested in the data here so
let's not take the header
value so let's say b2 and then we can
go all the way to the end so we can
basically select this way
that's the data we have select this and
hit
enter so now here
it has selected b2 to b4 but we need to
basically now give the criteria so the
criteria
is either a value or you can point it to
a cell
which has that particular value so as
per our problem statement
we are looking for the units which are
sold in east region
so i can select the value east here and
then
my sum if needs the range on which you
want to
calculate a sum so
let's select this and now we are
interested in finding out the sum of
units
so that's basically this column e column
so i can basically type in instead of
selecting
so i can say e and i'm interested in e2
2
e 44 so that basically selects the area
or all the values and now let's do this
so that basically gives me the sum is
691
right now this is the criteria where i
have pointed it to a cell
and whatever value that cell has well i
could have
done something like this so i could have
selected
east giving the value and then doing it
it still does the same thing and in this
way you have more clarity
that you are using sumif you are
filtering
the data so you have given the rows you
are
given the criteria and then you have
given the range
on which you would want to sum up the
values
now similarly if the question was what
was the total revenue generated from
binder now we would want to find out
what is the total revenue generated from
binders that means my filtering criteria
will be binder
and then i want to find out the total
revenue generated so we have the revenue
generated field
also here and we have we don't have any
region
to be filtered we are just looking for
binder
so let's again start doing the same
thing so we can go for some if
we can open the bracket now it needs the
range
so we are interested in revenue
generated
now that's the summation we want and we
would want to
get the range of data so
here we can basically select
uh d 2
2 d 44
so that's the data selected now i would
want to give the filtering criteria so
let's say
binder and then we need to give the
range on which the sum
needs to be calculated so that's my
revenue column so that's
g so i can say g
2 to g 44
and that basically selects the column
and then you get your sum
so it tells me what is the total revenue
generated
from binder now i could be doing this
for
other things also so say for example if
you would want to
filter out something else you could
basically
just drag and drop here and then i could
come here and change this
to say instead of binder i would be
interested in say pencil
if that's the criteria you're interested
in
remember to change this so that you take
all the values
and here we will change it
to select the relevant rows and then
this is the data i'm getting so i know
that this is
the revenue generated from pencil
this is the revenue generated from
binder now this is a simple use case
where we are using some
if what if we would want to use
some ifs so some ifs
let's have a look at how we get to some
ifs
so some if says where you would want
to work on doing some calculation
but then you would want
multiple criterias to be met so let's
see how we get this
so here what i can do is
let's work on this problem statement
which says what is the total revenue
generated from
central region where
the item is a pencil so
that's something which i would want to
check
now when we are answering this question
we can also look at the
order in which things have been asked in
the question so it says what
is the total revenue generated from
central region so we need the total
revenue generated we know there is a
revenue column
we are interested in getting the total
revenue generated
we are saying the filtering criteria is
central region
and we say in that we would be
interested
only in the item if it is pencil how do
i do it
so i can use sumifs where you can pass
in multiple criteria so
let's start with some ifs
and when i start with some ifs let's
open up the bracket so it says sum range
it says criteria range then it gives one
criteria
and you can give in any number of
criterias so for example we are
interested in total
revenue generated now that's my g column
so let's
follow in the same order so let's say g
2
so that's my first value and then i know
there are 44 rows here so i can say g
44 and you can obviously check
if that has selected all the rows
now that's my total revenue generated
so i would want the total revenue
generated so i'm
saying setting this sum range
then i need to give the criteria range
so it says
from central region so central region
comes into column 2 that's b
so let's say b 2 to b 44
so that's my criteria range then
you have to give your criteria but
we need to filter out the region being
central
so let's select this now either i could
point
to a value in the cell or i can just
give the exact value here we can also
give
a wild card or matching pattern so that
also works
now this one is fine we are now
also interested in finding the total
revenue generated
when the region is central and the item
is pencil
how do we do that so for item
we know the columns the column is d2
so let's select d2 2
d 44 so that basically selects
all the rows in the d column and we need
to give the
filtering criteria so let's do a comma
and then just given our value so let's
say
pencil and then let's close your bracket
and that basically gives you the result
so
we need to just follow the order of our
question which says
what is the total revenue generated so
we are looking at the revenue column
we are selecting all the rows then it
says
from the central region so we need to
select the region column
and give the filtering criteria central
or point to a
cell which contains that value and then
it says
we would be interested only in item
being pencil
so then you select the column which has
all the items
and provide your filtering criteria that
is
pencil so that's your easy calculation
of using sum
if which we compare with sum if here
so sum if here was just
having your criteria
so basically you are selecting your rows
giving your filtering criteria
and then your sum range in some ifs
we are giving multiple condition now
same thing can be done here
it says how many units were sold by
sales representative
john's or jones where the cost of each
item was greater than four
so how many units were sold
by sales representative
so when we talk about how many units
that's your
e column so let's start with that
so let's say some ifs i would be
interested in
e column
then let's give the range so it says sum
range
so those are the number of units on
which we would want to find
the sum then it says you need to give
the criteria range
so we say sales representative where the
name is
jones so sales representative is in
sales rep
column c so let's say c2
to c44 now
then we need to give our filtering
criteria so let's say
jones is the sales representative where
we are interested
about whom we are interested in and then
we
the question says where the cost of each
item
so cost of each item is what we are
interested in
you have unit cost so that's what we are
interested
in so that would be f and then say
f2 to f44 and then
you need to give your cost
so it says where each item
is greater than
4 so let's select this
and let's do this
so this tells me 3 0 1
now similarly
let's answer our third question which
says how many units did jones sell
excluding pencil item
so we would want to find out what was
the total number of units
units that were sold
and that units
or that should not include the pencil
item how do we start doing this
so let's start with some ifs
now we know that you start with some ifs
you need to give the sum
range so we are interested in the number
of units
so let's basically go in and select
our number of units which were sold so
that's your
column e so i can say e2
to e44 that's where i would want to
perform this
sum now i'm saying
how many units that were sold where
we are talking about sales rep being
jones so
let's see let's select the columns
c and then give
the range after that we need to give our
giving
filtering criteria which is jones and
then we are interested
in the items but
excluding pencil so items
is in column d so let's say d
to d 44 and then
we have to give our
criteria so we can say well that should
exclude
pencil so i can basically say
pencil
and let's close this
and let's check so that's my formula
which says
that these are the number of units which
the sales representative whose name is
jones had
sold and that does not include
pencil as an item let's also look at an
example of using countif or countifs
now both of these can be very useful
when you would want to calculate certain
values
so for example if i would want to work
on count f let's try
solving this problem now remember
you can answer these questions using
filters
and that can be an easier way but then
sometimes you may want to
get the formulas so that you can make
your spreadsheet and your calculation
more dynamic in nature
and that will basically depend on the
values in the
columns or rows so for example if i have
find the total number of times
gil has made a sale now if i look at my
data here
it tells me that for every sales
representative there is some value
in the sale and it says sales has
greater than three
so for example jones you have sales
greater than
3 or you have jardine which is
sales greater than 3 and so on so what
we are interested
in is doing a quick count in finding out
the total number of times gill has made
a
sale how do we do that so we can use
this count
if function and if i go into countif
it says counts the number of cells
within a range that meet the given
condition
now what's our condition our condition
is
kill and we would want to find out how
many times the name
say gill appears or kill has made
a sale now i could just say count
if and then open up a bracket i need to
give a range
so let's say we are interested in
looking
at the range so let's say
we will choose sales rep so i can say
c and then i can say c2
to c44 now
that's my range
let's not give that in quotes
so you have to give a range so let's do
a count if
that selects the data and then we need
to give the
condition so for example let's here give
the name which is
gil and then close this
so that basically tells me it is five
times
kill appears here we can check this so i
can go in here
i can add a filter
and then might be i would be interested
interested in looking at
only gil and that basically gives me
5 right so we can always do that
and we can be using formulas like this
now
what about this question so which
basically says
which sales representative made a sale
more than three times now we
it might be looking a little confusing
when i
say for example let me clear out this
filter
now we have sales greater than three
and we would want to find out which
sales representative
made a sale more than three times
now i could basically check for every
sales representative here if they have
made
a sale more than three times and what i
can do is i can just
say equals i can start with count if
then i need my filtering criteria
so that's your range so first thing is
we will choose for example let's choose
c2
to c 44 and then
we need to give
and criteria what is the criteria we
need basically a sales representative
so i can choose the value here in c2
and then i can close this and then i can
say
the sale has to be greater than three
and let's check
so it tells me the boolean value that
yes
this guy has made sales more than three
times
and what we can do is we can just drag
and drop
which basically gives me the value for
other sales rep
you can always check the value is
automatically changing to this value in
cell and for example let's go in here so
this is
obviously two so it says me false right
and you can basically get the values for
all your values so that basically tells
me
which sales representative has made a
sale
more than three times now like
some ifs we also have countifs where you
can give multiple criterias
so for example the question is how many
orders were placed from the
east region after this particular date
so we have a date criteria
we also have the region criteria and we
need to
basically get the count of number of
orders which were placed
now i can in this case use count
ifs and this basically says that
you can start within criteria so it says
how many orders were placed from
east region after particular
date so date is in my
first column so for example i could say
a start with 2 and
say for example let's go a 44
that should have selected all the rows
and then i need to once i've given the
criteria range i need to give the
criteria
so we are saying the date has to be
greater than 10th feb
so let's give it 2
10 2019
and then you need to say how many
orders were placed so you need to give
the criteria
second criteria range so we are looking
at the number of
orders which were placed from
the east region so
when i would want to look at the region
that's your column b
so i can basically say b2 to b
44 and here
i would basically give my criteria so
the criteria
is east
let's give that and once you have done
this
you would want to find out the total
number of orders so let's select this
and if i do this it tells me 13.
now is that right so we are looking
for your date
your region being east and then getting
the total number of orders
so here i can just do a count if
i'm saying a2 to a44
wherein i have given the date criteria
that it should be greater than
10th feb because i do not want to count
10 feb it says
after 10 february and then you are
saying the region
has to be east so we would want to find
out the total number of orders so
my region is east and that gives me the
result
now similarly you can also find out how
many times gil
sold pencils so here we will have to
give the range
so let's start with count
ifs now here i would want
that item is pencils so we can as well
select
column d to d
44
then you have to give your criteria so
that's your
pencil and then
we are looking for sales rep which is
kill
so that is my column
c so let's say c 2
2 c 44
and the value should be just
kill
so it tells me it's twice
where gil has sold pencils so we can
obviously check this by going in here
choosing my filter and then
let's search for rep being just
gill okay
and now we are interested only in the
item being pencil
so i can say well let's get to pencil
only
and that tells me twice so you can
obviously re-verify using filters
but using functions or using formulas
it is always good to calculate and
that can be making your computation and
calculation more
dynamic let's look at one more
interesting feature of
excel and that's your conditional
formatting
now as you see on the screen conditional
formatting has
different rules which can be applied on
your data
and that allows you to basically
differentiate
or easily identify data values
which are based on
certain criterias or rules so when you
talk about conditional formatting you
have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values
you can apply different rules apply
different color scales and you
you can easily manage these rules
so conditional formatting is very useful
for people who would want to work on
huge amount of data
and easily perform some data analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here
and with your conditional formatting you
can format
cells based on a preset condition you
can
perform conditional formatting to
identify
cells you can highlight a few
significant cells and you can easily
perform conditional formatting
as shown on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look
so say for example we have our excel
sheet and if you see here
i am highlighting the sales person
who have generated revenue greater than
10 000
so we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person
is greater than 10 000 it has a
particular
color and how do we get here
so for example let's select this
data and what i could do is
i could go into conditional formatting
now i could
basically highlight cell rules and we
could just say greater than that's an
easier way
i could also go ahead and create a new
rule
but then i can use one of this option i
can say greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be interested in looking at
any value greater than twelve thousand
so let's choose twelve
thousand
and here it says what color would you
want to select
so for example i would say
something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay so right now what i'm
doing is
i have all the values where the revenue
generator was greater than 10
000 but then i have also selected
all the sales people who have made
or who have generated revenue greater
than twelve thousand
so i can just wait ctrl z to see
the previous result now here i had the
values which were greater than ten
thousand
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000.
so this is one simple example now we can
look at some other examples
say for example you want to format cells
using three color scale
so if you look at the values here i have
a three color scale
mainly in green yellow and red
and how do you do this so for example i
can go in here
and i can go to conditional formatting
so i would want to
go for color scales and here you can
create different rules
so we can set up a two color scale
so we can say format only values that
are above and below
average i can format only cells that
contain
something i can get the top and bottom
values so these are different ways in
which
i can have a three color
based scale now what i will do is i will
select this
and let me show you the rule which i
have so for example
i can go into manage rules and if you
see here there are certain rules which
have been specified
now what does that mean so you would
want to
specify a three grade scale
so for example if i would want to look
at my first rule
it tells me that i am choosing three
color scale
i can choose lowest value percentile and
highest value
and that basically will select
the cells based on their values so
what we could have done is i can
basically
use one of these values i can delete
these rules which i have created
so for example i have all these
rules but you should always carefully
remember
that the rules will be applied in the
order
shown so for example if i just delete
these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back
now it does not have any highlighting
now i can go in here
i can say condition sorry conditional
formatting
i could go for color scale so i could
basically
go into new rule
so i would want the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale
it says what will be the color of lowest
value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red
i can say midpoint is percentile 50
and then the highest value is green and
if that looks good let's say
okay and now if you see the lowest
values have been highlighted as red
you have mid values and then
you have the positive value so this is
the three color scale and that
easily helps me in identifying the data
based on the cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do
is you can basically color the cells
based on their value so what we are
seeing here
is if the revenue generated
is greater than average then that
shows in green and if the revenue
generated
is lesser than average that's shows
in orange now how do we do that so we
can
basically again manage some rules so i
can basically create a new rule
now here i can select one of the options
which says format
only values that are above or below
average
and that's the option i would want to
select now i can select this
and it says format values that are above
average so in our case we had it in
green so for example i'll say above
average
and then here i can go for
a particular color so you can go for a
particular size
so let's go and look into
the formatting so for example let's
choose yellow say okay
now i'm saying wherever the
cell values are above average it would
be
yellow instead of green and
let's go in here let's go and look into
manage rules
so this is basically the rule which we
are applying now we can
also add a new rule and
i need to select the values so for
example
i will say
here so we had gone for above now we
will go for below
we'll go for format we will choose red
we'll say okay we'll say now
these are basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to
your data so right now it has not been
applied
so for example if i select this and then
i could basically choose my area
just hit on enter and similarly you can
go in here
and then select your area
hit on enter and say apply say
okay and now if you see i have really
chosen bright colors but then
i have said wherever my revenue
generated is
above average it should be in yellow
and below average should be in red
so we wanted above average
to be in green and below average to be
in
orange so that's what we have here
right so you can always color code
your cell values based on some rules
which you are setting up
now similarly you can also
find the top 10 and bottom 10 values
and that's pretty easy so you can just
select
this and then you can go into
conditional formatting you can go for
top and bottom values top
10 items bottom 10 items
or you can go in for more rules so you
can say
format only top or bottom ranked values
so you have top 10 now you can choose
the color and for example i'll go for
blue and
i'll say okay so now if you see my top
10 values are blue now similarly i can
add one more rule
so i can say new rule and i can say
let's go for top or bottom let's go for
bottom let's go for format let's say
orange say okay say okay
and that's it so now you have your
values which
are top or bottom 10 values
so you are using conditional formatting
where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors
and here easy conditional formatting
based on different rules helps us to do
that
now similarly you can also
have the values which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing so what
we can do is we can select our
columns either you could apply this to
all the columns now here
i have applied this only to jan and
april
now i could apply this for june so let's
say
june so you can go for gradient fill you
can go for
solid fill you can obviously just select
the color and that takes care of the
things
you can say for example select this and
now this is selected but i would want to
might be format this so i can go in here
i can go into manage rules now that will
tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so i can just do a edit
rule
and that basically says this is a solid
fill
which is color you have no border this
is basically color is black
now i can go for something like gradient
fill
and i can say okay and now if i say
apply
and okay so this basically is like your
first column
so you can use conditional formatting
for various use cases
and you can highlight the values so
anyone who would look at the value would
automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be
here the revenue is getting generated
or was getting generated but did not
grow beyond a particular value
and so on now similarly you can
also go in for different options
say for example here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased or say for
example if the revenue was going
up for this particular sales person so
here we are looking at carol
so in jan the revenue generation by
sales was very high
then in feb it was falling down
in march it was kind of stable
then in april it went way below so we
can
obviously work on this wherein we can
grade our cell values so what we can do
is we can go in for
highlighting the cell values now you can
go for color scales
you can go for icon sets and this is
where
you can choose your different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
i would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional
i could go using this three arrows
i can go in for this color i can choose
directional
and then my values are
automatically using directional
now what we can also do is we can then
go into manage
rules and that basically tells me
what rules have been applied so for
example the latest one is the icon
set which i have chosen it shows the
selected columns
i can obviously do a edit rule and then
i can choose
so i'm saying the format style is icon
sets i'm not using a data bar i'm not
using color scale
now here i have chosen the style of
icons
and then here you can basically give
some values
so you have icon which is green when the
value is greater than or equal to
67 percentage when i say
hyphen or minus it is less than 67.
it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit
and easily highlight your cell values
based on
this icon set so i can apply this
and that's how i use conditional
formatting so conditional formatting can
be very useful
if you would want to use icon set
if you want to use your data bars if you
would want to
highlight particular values if you would
want to color code based on
some calculation if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to
just find out values based on some
simple
calculation so conditional formatting is
used extensively
by data analysts or people who are
working business intelligence teams or
people who would want to use
excel to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value
or finding out less significant or more
significant cells
to then pull out values and carry out
your computations calculations or
analysis let's continue learning on
using excel for various things now we
have learnt on conditional formatting
and seen how that can be very helpful
let's learn one more feature of excel
and that's basically your data
validation
now this can be very useful when you
would want to work
on validating the data which is being
fed in the cells so you could limit it
to
basically a number between a particular
value
you could also add some messages to it
if you would want or you could even
circle invalid data or clear validation
circles
so data validation really helps us in
validating the data which is being fed
in
to particular fields now
it's a feature in excel which is mainly
used to control what a user can
fill in a cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered
you can also restrict user to enter
only valid data and if any invalid data
is entered an
error message will be displayed now
that's where you can use your data
validations
so let's see how that can be done so for
data validation let's
see some exercises here so for example
you have
a name column and you would want to
restrict
that the name should accept only 15
characters now how do you do that
so you can basically select the cells
or you can just select a particular cell
and then we can later
drag the property to other fields
now here once the cell is selected so
for example let's
try this out and let's see if that works
so for example i will say peter
johnson okay and that
is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
junior and if i do this
it says input length is greater than 15
do you want to continue
if i say yes right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then
it has basically violated the
rule now this is giving a message to the
user
that the username should be entered less
than 15 characters now how do we do that
so for this we can basically select the
column
and then we can search for data tab and
get into data
validation so this is where you can
create
or select different kind of rules so for
example
i can go into data validation i can go
into settings
and i can say the text length and
that should be less than 15 now this is
the maximum i'm giving
and it says apply these changes to all
other cells within the same
settings so i can do this or i can just
drag and drop so i can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact
randomly check in any particular cell is
the rule applied
so it says text length less than 15. so
we can basically
control data validation in this
particular column
and that will allow only 15 characters
it will pop up a message if the user
really wants to go beyond the
particular limit now you also have
similarly date of birth
so the restriction is date of birth
should be between 10 jan 1990
to 30 december 1998.
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that
so we can select the field we can click
on data validation and if you see here
i have selected date and then date is
between
and then obviously you can give a range
that is 10 jan date 1990
12 30 1998 so that's the start and the
end
filter which has been applied and once
this is done
you can also check your input messages
which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid
date so if you see here on the left
there is a pop-up which is coming up it
says enter a valid date
now i can also say when user enters
invalid data
show this error alert so i can say stop
i can say invalid entered
and this is how i have set a rule so for
example if i just do
something like this and that says
invalidate
entered i can do a retry it will take me
back here but
unless and until i did not
give the right format the date will not
be accepted
and again the same thing applies to all
the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have
at the rate present in the value
provided now for this
we can use a formula and we can select
well i would want to apply this rule to
all these rows starting from c2
to c14 so let's get into data validation
let's look in settings and here we
are choosing custom now within custom
i am choosing what is the formula
so i am saying is number
and then i am saying find at the rate
for the rows c2 to c14
so the only thing we are concerned about
here
is the value should have an email
icon you can input a particular message
you can say what has to be done for
error alert so for example we can
basically go in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title i'm giving and we can
say
email should contain
at the rate so if i do this and if i say
ok
now you can test it so you can say a b c
d and that says email should contain at
the rate
and basically that will not allow me to
add the values
so now you have the field called salary
it says salary should be
greater than 50 000 now we can limit the
values
by choosing a whole number
so for example for salary i can go into
data validation
i can go into settings so here i can say
something like decimal or i can go for
whole number so both of the things are
fine it depends on what kind of values
get into this particular field
so if i say whole number and if i say it
has to be greater than 50
000 so i'm saying the minimum is
50 000 or i could have given a decimal
and then i can say greater than less
than
equal or anything or even between
so i can select greater than and then i
can just say
okay now for rank the rule is
rank should be between 100 and 200
so again we can use a whole number so
ranks will
generally not be decimal so this would
be whole number
salary is can be a whole number
or it could be decimals so we have
chosen decimal here
and in rank if you click on data
validation
i have chosen whole number
i've set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends i can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell
okay so now let's also understand
how we can restrict the values in a
particular cell
which might be based on a list of items
now for example here if you see i have
two columns
so one column basically has the values
of city
names and then you have places within
that particular city
so if i would want to implement a data
validation
based on this so for example if you see
here
city and that basically shows me only
the four values which can be entered
and if i go to place then it tells me
for
maharashtra i can only enter pune mumbai
nasik now how do i do this so say for
example you take an empty field and you
want to restrict the values of city
names
so i could select data validation
i could basically select list and then
it tells me
you need to enter the list values that
is the source
so you click here and then i can just
select these fields
now if i do this and if i say ok
it has implemented a data validation but
if you look into this
it will show me the same thing but then
it shows me some empty cells which
did not have any value so this is fine
but it would be better
if we do it in a different way so i can
select this
and i have already given my city names
here so i can just do a data validation
and here in the source let
me get rid of this now
i can just have my cursor here
i can select these values and then if i
say okay
so now if you see my city names have
been restricted to
these values and that's how you can
implement
your data validation so i have
this data validation here but i will get
rid of this one
by just doing a control z now i'll come
here
and say for example i would want to
implement the same data validation
now the easiest way would be in doing
this
for all my four cities now if you see
here
i have data validation i could choose
bangalore
and if you come and check here there is
no data validation but we have
implemented data validation here now how
is that done
so i could select this or for example i
can go in here
i can select data validation i can
select
list and then here in the source
i will say for bangalore the value
should be
these and then if i basically say
okay now if we see
these are the values which are fed into
bangalore
so we could do this or like what we have
done
here so if you can check the data
validation rule
i have used list and then i have said
indirect f2 so basically
i'm giving in a formula which relates to
the value which is in for the city
maharashtra
so we could do this or in a simpler way
we could do this
and then just drag and drop here so we
could check
for maharashtra what are the values
let's choose a different city
so for example kolkata and here i will
choose
now since we did a drag and drop it has
basically taken the values of bank load
so that's not right
so we select this we go into data
validation and
here i can either
feed in the values that is such as
bangalore
i could basically say something like
this
kolkata and i could say okay
so now if you see it shows me the places
in kolkata
now here we have let's choose a
different city so for example let's go
for delhi
and here i can go to data validation
and i can just say delhi so this is an
easier way
of doing it or if you remember the
formula
then what you can do is you can
just give in indirect and then basically
give the value of the cell
for which you would want to keep in the
values
so this is how you can do list
validation so you can provide a list of
values
and then you can restrict the values
in a cell which should be belonging to
a particular list so this is how you do
a
simple data validation by restricting
the
data in the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables which is
one more very useful feature of excel
and which allows you to
work with your data or perform data
analysis now
pivot table is a summary of your data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set
and it allows you to group your data in
several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it
now the visual representation of a pivot
table is termed as
a pivot chart now how do we do that so
let's see an example
now here is some data here you see we
have some row labels which basically
gives me
some category of items here
it also tells me the sum of sales and
basically it gives me
per item what is the total sum
of sales which were made now how do i
get this here
so for example if i would want to delete
this and i would be interested in
getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have different data
here
and it's huge for example on the
row end if i just do a control and right
arrow it tells me what's my right
last column and if i just do a control
and down arrow it tells me there are
9994 rows
now i can use this and what i can do is
i can basically work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since
i have chosen my first row and first
column
it basically has selected the data and
that's fine
now do you want the result in a new
worksheet i'll say
existing worksheet and i can choose a
location now that basically needs me to
select a field
might be we can just select this field
and that
should be good enough so for example if
i close this
or if i say okay so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table
will be created now what are the fields
we are interested in
so as per the problem we need to find
out what the total sales for
each category so let's go in here
and let's select the field category now
as soon as you do that
it shows that the rows
which are being selected are for this
column category and now we are
interested in getting the sales
so we would want the sales per category
so let's select this
so you see some of sales is selected now
close this
and that's it that's that's your data so
it shows you row labels
it tells you what are the different
categories
and it also gives you sum of sales
which is per category now this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category
of items so for example let's have
another data set so again you can just
check how many rows we have
and it is basically the same 9994
and if i look in columns it basically
shows me
profit is the last column and
here we would want to find out
which category so for example let me get
rid this
with subcategory of items sold the
maximum under
each category so we have some categories
here
which says furniture and it shows some
sub categories
and then it shows me office supplies and
then some sub categories and same thing
with technology
now we know how we got this data but
this is different than what we were
seeing here
so here we were just getting the
categories but but we did not have any
breakdown
of sub categories within this particular
category
and here you see there is a breakdown
and then basically you can also
apply a filter which basically says
what is the data you want and if you are
interested in
finding out a particular value now how
do we do this
so for example let me get rid of this
now we know how we can find out the
category of items
but we would want to find out which
subcategory of items sold the maximum
under each category so here we are not
looking at sales but we are looking at
the quantity
okay so what we can do is we can go to
the first row and first column click on
insert
click on pivot table data is already
selected
let's choose existing worksheet let's
choose a location in our worksheet where
we would want
to have this so might be i can select
this particular field and then just
close this
so it says this is the existing
worksheet say ok
and now you need to select your columns
so for example if
i would want the data for categories so
i can select this now i know
that within category these are the
options which we have and then there is
a sub category so let's select
that and if you see here now we have
the data which will be filtered so based
on your category
and subcategory and then we will choose
quantity
so it automatically understands that
this is something on which
summation can be done so let's select
this
and close on this now if you see here
we have got our items where
we can see the sub categories
within a particular category now i can
basically close this and that just shows
me
high level categories here so here
i can again select a particular
row and column i can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected
existing worksheet is what i want so
now i will select this particular
place say okay now we do the same thing
like what we did earlier
so we will select category sub category
and quantity so the data has already
come in
just select this and now you already
have
all your data but this is not what we
want we want to
basically apply a filter to this now how
do we do that
so we can go for slicer
so i can go for insert slicer and then
it tells
what are the sub categories which you
are interested
in so for example if i go for
something like subcategory and say okay
so this tells me what are the categories
you are interested
in so for example we know that furniture
has furnishings with the highest value
so i can select say furnishings
and then i was interested in office
supplies
so within office supply i can basically
search for here
binder so i can just do a control and
select binder
and then i can also know for technology
i can select phones so i'll say control
and select
phones and now if you see the filter has
been applied
and we have these sub categories which
are selected
so we have our data here now we don't
need really this so i can just delete
this
and i have my data which shows me
furniture being the main category and
that has only furnishings
office supply having binders and
technology having phones and that
basically
is a filter applied on the result of
your pivot so this is how we are seeing
which sub category of items were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis
let's look at some more examples
now let's see if you have to answer this
question which says
which were the top three states for each
region that made the highest average
profit
now how do we calculate that so for
example this is the data we have
and as i have instructed earlier you can
select the first row and first column
you can click on insert go into pivot
table
and that basically selects all your data
we will choose the result should be in
this existing worksheet
so select this click here and then
basically
let's select this cell
and i will say okay so now my pivot
table will be here so we
are interested in finding out top three
states
within each region which have made the
highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit
so for that first we will select
region so when we select region it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state
so within every region you have multiple
states
so that's what we are selecting and then
we are interested in looking at the
profit
so let's select profit and that
automatically shows up here
so we can now say close this so
basically we have all the data but we
are looking at the sum of profit but
that's not what we want
we are looking for top three states from
each region that made the highest
average
profit now how do we change that so
here we have sum of profit so i can do a
right click
and basically i can say summarize values
by
average so now i'm getting the average
here
and that basically tells per region
i have the average profit but first is
let's sort this data so let's go into
sort more
options and here i have
average of profit or for example
as i said you can select region say okay
and now it is basically having the
regions and then you have your
state value so again we can do a sorting
here
and i can say let's go for more sort
options
i'll say descending the state values
should be based on average profit so
let's say okay
and now if you see in particular region
we have the data which has been
sorted wherein you have the highest
average profit on the top
now what we can also do is we can
basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but i'm not interested in top 10
so i could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay
and now you see per region you have
the data which is showing me
top three states what are the average
and then
you are also looking at the subtotal so
which basically says
average profit for your west now if you
would want to arrange this
your west and south and east and central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it
you can always do a sorting and you can
choose sort z
to a if that's what you would want to do
or you can go for sorting
more sort options and you want to
sort the region which is as of now
based on descending z2a let's make it
ascending
say okay and now you see the data has
been filtered
so it says per region now
you can always select this and you can
say what is this
so this is basically your average of
profit
now we are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted
within the region and what is the
average
now we have one more question what is
the percentage contribution of
each sub category of products
under each category to the total sales
so we know there are different products
there are different categories
and all the categories contribute to the
total sales
so we would want to find out what is the
percentage contribution of each
sub category of products
under each category so we not only want
the
category percentage but we would also
want what is the contribution of each
sub category to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that
so for that we need to again
just place our cursor here or select the
first row and first column
click on your insert click on your pivot
table
and now the data is already selected
existing worksheet
place your cursor here and then let's
select this
cell say okay now your pivot table
fields are here so we
are interested in category so let's
select
category and then within a category we
will have subcategories and we are
interested in the sales data
wherein it is already going to give us
the sum of sales
but we would want this in the form of
percentage
rather than just the sum now we can
click here value field settings
and it says if you would want to
summarize this it says show value
as and what are the values you would
want so
you can straight away go ahead here and
say percentage of grand total
so we could do that because we know we
will get
a sum of sales and grand total now i
could basically say
in the percentage of grand total say
okay
and then just close this so once
you have closed this you see already
the data is in percentage
so now we have our data with sub
categories but we also want
the data to be sorted might be in a
descending order which tells
which sub category is contributing more
than others
we can select how many sub categories we
are interested in
so we can basically select one of the
sub category cells
right click now you have option filter
and you have sorting so we can say more
sort
options now here i will say descending
and you want the descending to be
sum of sales which is already showing as
percentage
click on ok and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales
it shows the sub categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total
sales so technically speaking if you
look at
all these values which are sub
categories and if you would total
them that would be your total grand
total
so this is how we can solve a simple
problem like this
what is the percentage contribution of
each subcategory of products
under each category to the total
sales the next question is which
customer made the lowest profit
in the home office segment in each state
now here we know
that we are looking for home office
segment
we are looking for customer which made
the lowest profit
we are also looking for the state
as the main criteria so in each state
we would look for home office segment
and within that we would look for
customer which has made the lowest
profit that means
the lowest value of the profit
so how do we do this so let's say let's
get into
selecting our row and column we will go
into insert
i'll say pivot table i'll say existing
worksheet
and let me get my result
here so let's say okay now that gives me
the pivot table so the first thing
is we are looking at per state
and i would be interested in
[Music]
home office segment or i could first
start with
segment now here we have segment
and in segment i can basically select
home office so i can just do a uncheck
and select
home office only and now
i can select state
so that will be my sub category within
segment
and then within state we would want to
find out the customer so let's get the
customer name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit
and here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected
close this and now you have your data
which basically shows me the names of
customers which made the
profit but it's it's not sorted so we
can sort this
and we have state entries also so that's
fine
so what i can do is here i can basically
say sorting go to more sort options
i can say i want to do it descending or
i want to do an
ascending and ascending based on
sum of profit so let's do that now you
see
the topmost value is the lowest value
per
state within home office segment
now what we also want is we just want
one value
per state so how do we do that so we can
just
go for filtering go for top 10 values
i'm interested in bottom value and in
that
also i'm looking for only the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state customer who has made the
lowest profit so we have easily answered
this question
using our pivot table now say for
example we have a question which says
find the sales
made in each quarter of 2016 for
all the regions so the data has to be
divided quarterly
and use order year as a slicer
we can do that by selecting what data we
would want to slice
and then we would want to create a pivot
chart
also so for example how do we do that so
for example
i will get rid of this i will get rid of
this my pivot chart which we can
recreate
so find the sales made in each quarter
of 2016 for all the regions
so this is what we want now how do we do
this
so for example let's select this
we will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say
existing worksheet and then i can select
this particular cell
i'll say okay and now i'm interested in
data quarterly
so first let's select our field here
so we should basically have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if i say
order date now
you see we have quarters and years
which are selected now we could be
selecting these fields which says
quarters years and if i would want
data to be filtered based on years i
could do that or i could get rid of here
so i have quarters
i have ordered date so
that's being already selected now what
else we need
we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region
and we can also add region as a column
here
so that will basically give me all the
regions
as different columns and then finally we
want the sales so let's select this
and now let's look what we have so if
you see
here we have our data
which is for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in
is not looking at the total data but we
are only interested in
quarter of 2016. now how do we do that
so what we do here is we have row labels
so let's click on this so we have date
filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016 and the value has to be
1 and then let's select
this and let's change this to 2016
and this is 12th month
and then we can say 31.
so we are saying the date has to be
2016.
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select let's select a
particular date and see
so the month has to be here so let's see
in this
and let's make it date and say okay
and now we have our data which is
for 2016.
so for example i could basically select
this
and here i could be looking at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from
order data so we have applied the filter
on
order date and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date 16 oh this is wrong
so this one has to be changed to 2016.
so select this and now we have our data
for 2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value
or for individual months in a particular
quarter
and we have sliced the data now we could
have
also introduced a slicer
by selecting which field
we would want to implement so for
example if i would
select a particular field and then i
could click on slicer
i could choose i would want to slice the
date based on order date and then
could have done it or we have just given
the
date for 2016. now we just need to
plot a graph for this and that's very
easy so you just need to
select the complete pivot data
and here you have the chart options so
let's go for
line chart and that basically shows me
the line chart so we can select this
we can just drag and drop it here and
then
we can basically check if that is
showing us
the data so if you see here this is line
chart where it has divided the regions
in different colors
so we have all the regions we could
filter out in pivot chart a particular
region
we have the quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied
it says it is 2016. in quarters it tells
me
it is 16. so we have our data we have
created a pivot chart
and basically we have sliced the data
for
2016. let's answer
one more question and that's finding the
profit made in
each year for all the categories
of products in east and west regions
only and then we would want to create a
histogram
for the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the
frequencies so let's look at how do we
calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories
so what i can do is i can basically
select my row id here and now i'll do a
pivot table
so the data is already selected i'll
choose existing worksheet let's select
this particular cell
say okay now what are we interested in
now if you look at the fields we don't
see any
years or quarters and so on so for
example here i can just choose
order date and then basically
i can choose say for example
years or quarters the data which is
coming out from my order date so
here i will just select years
now then i have my
order date so we are interested in
the years orders and
we are interested in let's look at our
column or the question what we had here
so we have years find the profit made in
each year
so let's select profit so that basically
says sum of profit
but then i'm on also interested in
for all the categories of products
so what i can do is here i have
my field which is category and that i'll
add to the columns
so that shows me what are the different
categories
and this looks fine now i'm also
interested in
east and west regions so that is
basically in the region
so either we could add a slicer or we
could do a filtering here
by adding the filters so first is i'll
click on
region and here it says select all i'm
only interested in east and west so
let's select this
take this put it here
let's say okay and now we have the data
which has been filtered
based on the region so here we have
region
so you can always look at the filter it
is east and west
and we have our year data
per year we have different categories
you can always look at what are these
column labels so this is
my different categories and this is the
profit
per category and then you have your
grand total
so we have already our data now let's
say
close this so we have our data for all
these years
different categories the profits made
per year
and if i would want i could go into an
year
and i could look into different months
so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data
so i can just place my cursor here
i can select this and then i can go into
insert and here i have different options
so we can go for
bar chart we can go for insert hierarchy
chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here
and we will go for a simple histogram
which is two dimensional
let's select this and here you see you
can
obviously select different regions
you have your ears which shows up
you have your order date and then you
have your categories which can be chosen
for your histogram
or for your bar chart and that basically
is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot
your needed graph to visualize the data
and understand it in a better way
hi everyone welcome to this tutorial on
microsoft
excel let's look at an example of
one more useful function in excel
and that is vlookup now vlookup is used
to see
if a value exists in a range of values
and we can create a range of values
which is nothing but
a block of cells which has a name
and can be referenced so mainly to use
vlookup we need to create a named range
and that can be referenced anywhere in
the workbook
or the other option is you can always
drag and select
uh the range of data in which you would
want to search something
now there is also other functions such
as hlookup
which pretty much does the same thing
however
it does it horizontally that is left to
right instead of vertically
there are other functions like lookup
and x lookup and so on
so when we talk about vlookup let's see
how we do that
so for example this is the range of or
this is the data which has been given to
you
and here is the question find the
employee name with employee id
107. now assume that you might have
huge amount of data and you may want to
search something
so how do we do it now here i have
created some
column and then some basic formatting i
have given it as an employee id
i've given employee name now what i can
do is
i can create a range of data now how do
i do that or a named range
so what you can do is you can select the
data
and then you can do a right click now
here you
have something like get data from table
range
so you can do that you can define a name
so you can click on this and here
you can give a name to the range what
you would want to
call it so for example let's say our
search now that's the named
range i'm creating and just say okay so
the scope is workbook
and i've created a named range which you
can see
here so it shows for search our search
so you have created a named range now
how do we do a vlookup here
so for that we can use a formula so for
example i would want to search for
employee name
where employee id is whatever you would
want to search for
so employee id we can give here 107.
now that's what we would want to search
then employee name
for and employee name is what we are
interested now what we can do is we can
use the function
option here i can do a insert function
and that shows me different functions
which are
here now vlookup is showing up because i
have recently searched for it
or you can basically just type in here
look and you can do a go so that shows
you
all the lookup options what you have
like lookup edge lookup
match vlookup and so on so we would be
interested in vlookup
so let's select that and click on ok now
that basically
opens up this function arguments and it
shows what does this function
do so it says looks for a value in the
leftmost column of a table
and then returns a value in the same row
from a column you specify
by default the table must be sorted in
an ascending
order now you can basically say this
is what you would want to search for
what is the lookup value
if you place your cursor here it says
what is the table
array that is nothing but the range
which we can use our named range
here we have the column index number
which basically tells me
what is the column number in the range
which we want
so what is the value we want from which
column
and then basically you have range lookup
which basically
is the fourth option and range lookup is
nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then
false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value
we would want to give a particular
value which is nothing but
we would be interested in say employee
name
so i can basically
search for a value based on the lookup
value now how do we do it
so we are saying we would want to search
for employee id which is 107.
so what i can do is i can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value or employee id for which i would
want to search the employee name
i could actually select the
cell here which is h so that whatever
value you feed in here you can search
for that value so might be we can select
this one which is
h6 and whatever value we key in here
we will be searching for employee name
for that
employee id now table array is we would
want to give a range
so what we can do is we can give our
range so for example we had selected
something like our
search and if you see here that
already selects or shows me employee id
employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now
column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column
so i can just say 2 and that basically
is the column number and then you have
to give a range
lookup which is a logical value so
either you give an exact match
or you can basically give a
closest match so we can say for example
do a 0 which basically means false
or you can say 1 which is true so let's
go for 0
now that's our formula so it says
vlookup you will search for the value as
per
h6 in the range and then you are looking
for employee name which is column number
two
and then true or false so let's click on
ok and that basically gives me the value
which is
parallel birch so
here i'm searching for employee name and
you can basically drag
this for other columns and you can do
that
so if it finds employee
id here now say for example if we had an
employee id somebody enters an employee
id which is
not in the range for example let's try
121 and then you see this is
basically an error right because it does
not
have any employee id with 121.
now how do i take care of this so there
is a formula
which is called if error and that can be
used to
take care of this so if the value is
not found then it will show
whatever i would want to show here so
what i can do is i can still select this
and what i can do is i can search in
function
say for example this is the function we
are looking at but what we can do
is we can test it here so for example if
i look in function
and if i search for error and say oh
go so there are lots of functions here
and this is the function we are
interested in if error so if i say
okay now this takes the value and what
is the value if
error so for value what i can do
is basically i can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula
and value if error so for example
i will basically say for example not
found so we can try this and we can say
okay
now here it says not found so whenever
it is n a
it is not found now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error
it takes the value of h7 which is
nothing but our vlookup
and then it is showing us the value
which we have entered so for example if
i would say
107 like earlier
and then hit on enter so it says panel
of cruise
and it shows us the value right
and if we enter something else
then basically here it shows any
and it shows not found but what we want
to do is we want to merge these two
so what i can do is i can get rid of
or i can basically take this one
now what i would want is i want
this formula to be here
so what i can do is i can say
if error and then basically
given your vlookup option or function
here
and then say for example not found
here not found now that basically will
take care of
any kind of error if the value is not
found
so when we say 121 it basically says not
found
but if i say 107 which is found
then it shows me the value so we are
using vlookup
but then we are also using if error
which will take care of our error
message
or basically the not applicable pound
not applicable to replaced with
whatever value we key in similarly we
can do the same thing here
so we have the find the job title so we
are interested in finding out the job
title
once the employee name is given now
employee name
can basically have a value from the cell
or whatever value you would want to key
in
how do we do it so we basically start
with
our v lookup so that's the
function we are interested in so you can
just do a double click
now you are interested in finding out
the value whichever is given here
so that's the lookup value
and then you are interested in
finding out the job title from the range
so i will still give
our range which basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range
and now i'm interested in finding out
the job title so that's
column number four and then
i can just give zero which is for false
so now we have given our vlookup but
that shows not applicable because
we have not given any employee name so
we can key in the value here
which says fred stone and now
if we are basically giving the value so
fred stone
now we will have to search if there is
any job title which is fred stone so
here is the value so that should be
showing up
let's check what has gone wrong so we
are giving our range
we are interested in finding out the
value but what the mistake what we did
here
was that when we want to search
for a value say for example let's take
this
vlookup and let's replace this value of
h12 with the
value here so and then basically
we will give our range we will save
which is the column we are interested in
and then give true or false so we can
also basically take care of this error
message
so for example let's take this complete
formula from
here and just
just copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for h6 which was employee id
now that's not what we are interested in
we are
interested in finding out the value
so let's take this one and replace
this with the value given here
and then i give my range i say which is
the column
i'm interested in so i'm interested in
looking for job title
and then let's search so it basically
tells me
not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example i go for function
and then i select vlookup and say for
example i say ok
now just look at the description here
looks for a value in the left most
column
of a table now earlier the range which
we had selected had the left
most column as employee id and that's
why
it was giving an error so how do we fix
that
so for example let's basically
remove this function from here now what
we
want to do is we would want to search
for the stock broker
now if you see here i have given a range
which is
b 1 to d 21
so we would want the value
for what we would want to search say
employee name
that should be the left most column so
so that's how we have our function
so let's do that so say for example the
name is given here
so we want a range so either we can
create
a range like earlier by selecting
say for example this data now am i
interested in salary
no i'm interested in job title right so
i can basically just select these three
columns
and then i can define a name so i can
say
our search to
and let's give a named range and that's
only because we would want to easily
reference or use that named search
or named range now here we would want to
use
vlookup but we would also do an if error
now within that we can say we
look up and then you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes
so basically this is my function we will
say
if the value is not found then we will
give this so you can create an external
structure
and then within your vlookup we will say
the leftmost column which we are
interested in
so that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either i can
directly select the value here in the
column b
or i will give the value whichever is
fed in here
the employee name then i need to give a
range
so let's select our range so that's your
hour search too
and then you need to select the column
number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column
so let's say three and then just give a
zero
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name
now let's try to find the job title of
fred stone
so i can just select or i can say equal
and then i can just given a value and
that basically shows me
the job title so this is how you use
vlookup
we have also used if error which
basically takes care of
error message if the value is not found
so for example we can test this
here we have fred stone so for example
if i just empty this and i point it to
something which does not exist so that
shows me not found
or if you just select this and then key
in a value
it shows you this might be we can just
type in
so if i say fred then basically it says
not found because we are looking for
exact match now if we had changed this
to the closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this
so there are different ways of doing it
so what we can do is we can always
go for the exact match
and that's basically the value and here
we can basically key in any value for
example
i would be interested in finding out
this one
and let's give this so you can search in
this way
so you can also have statements which
can be searching one related to other
now here the question was to find the
job title of fred stone
so let's type in fred stone and that
basically shows me
the job title which we are interested in
so
let's search for job
title let's go for exact match and then
search
so it is stock broker so if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be
interesting to see how horizontal lookup
or
edge lookup works it basically works in
the
on the same lines but here instead of
vertically searching through the columns
the range is more of
horizontally defined so we search
in rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you
and you have various columns so you have
employee id
you have your employee name you have
employee email address you basically
have the job title of different
employees
and then basically you have the salary
so this is the data which has been given
to you
and you are asked to search or you are
interested in
finding out say the salary based on
employee name
or job title based on employee id so
what we need to do
is we need to define the range here
now range can depend on what you are
searching for so for example when i'm
searching
employee name and salary so
i am interested in these four rows
when i'm saying employee id and job
title then might be
this is the range and i don't need
salary so i can create a named
range if we are interested in so that we
can easily search for it
or we can straight away give the
the first cell value which is basically
a
one here and then the last
value here which is g and then
you can give five so you can do that or
you can create a named range whichever
way you would want to do it
so for example we would want to create a
named range for our first question
which is find the salary of edin
connell using h lookup so we are
interested in this so let's select
these four rows all the way
for your columns now like we did earlier
we can just define a name might be we
can call it
our search three
and we can just give okay so that's the
named
range which we have created now what we
would want is we want to search for
the salary based on employee name so
here we can insert our function so let's
look up
and let's search for look and just click
on co
so here you have h lookup and basically
that's the function i'm interested in
say okay
so this says what is the lookup value
which you are interested in
so we are interested in finding out the
value based on the employee name
so for example let's select this cell
that gives us more dynamism and you can
add in any name and you can search for
the salary
or you can basically give the employee
name
exactly from the employee name value
here which is
d two so we can give addin
conal from here so let's select this
now table array so we need to give our
range so let's say our
search three then you need to give the
row
index number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number
and here you have row index number so
what are you interested in searching for
so we are interested in searching for
salary now in our range that is
basically the fourth
row remember we created a range from
employee name
to salary so let's give the row index
number which is 4
and the range lookup will say 0 which is
basically exact match
and that completes our formula so click
on ok
and that basically gives me the salary
for
edin connell now that's basically
because we have fed in the value here
and that is basically giving me this so
i can again
do if error if i would be interested in
to basically take care of error message
if the value is not found for that you
can look into
the previous example which is vlookup
now similarly
we are interested in finding out the job
title for employee
id one zero five how do we do that
so we need to use hlookup well we could
have done
with vlookup but here the data is more
arranged in the form of rows
so how do we do that so we can again use
hlookup
but and we can give a range or named
range
or let's for this time let's basically
key in our range manually so we can do
that
so let's go for h lookup now
what do we want to search for so we will
say this is the value
then we need to give a range now as i
said
if you would want to give a range
manually so for example i'll say a
and then i'll say a 1
colon and then i'm interested in
g and then the row will be 4
so salary row is not what we are we are
not interested in
so let's say g and then we can give 4
so that basically gives me the range
right
instead of having a named range so we
can do that
and then we need to give the row index
number so we are interested in finding
out the job title which is
basically in our range the fourth row
and then
give zero for true or false so if you
see here
it tells if it is one it is approximate
match
false is an exact match and we can close
this bracket
that completes our formula it takes the
value which is given in employee id
and then it will try to search for the
job title
so that basically shows wherever the
employee id is 105
the job title is fabricator again you
can use
if error wherein
your if error can then be working on
hlookup
and can take care of error so that if an
employee id is keyed
in for which there is no matching value
then it will not show you
a not applicable error in instead of
that
it will replace with the word whatever
you have specified
so in this way you can easily use
hlookup
to search from the range of data which
is
horizontally arranged and in the
previous example
we were seeing how you use vlookup
when the data is arranged vertically
so we have looked at vlookup and hlookup
and what we have seen is vlookup has a
limitation in one way that we need to
basically give a range where the
leftmost
column is the one which is used
now instead of that we might be
interested in
searching in specific columns and not
all the columns
well that can also affect the time taken
to search
for the data when we can select
particular columns or particular ranges
rather than selecting
all the data which has to be searched
for so for example
we have this question find the salary of
hank
saunders now that's the employee name
which
we have here and we would want to find
out the salary so what are the columns
we are interested in
so one is your employee name and one is
your salary and these are the only two
columns which we are interested in
so instead of using vlookup now like
i've shown earlier you can create a
named range for these two columns and
you can use that
or we can manually give the range here
so let's go for
lookup function here and lookup function
will basically help us in searching what
we are interested in
so we are interested in finding out the
employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name
so how do we do that so here in lookup i
can first
give the value which is here employee
name
now whatever employee name
is keyed in here we will be searching
for salary
of that employee now lookup function
needs a lookup
value so we are searching
based on employee name then it says
lookup vector
so we will basically then say what
is going to be our lookup vector so here
we need to give a range so what are we
interested
in we are interested in finding out the
salary based on employee name
so first goes our range based on which
we need to search
so that's your employee name so let's
for example
select this one so that's our range b1
to b21
so that will basically have the employee
name in which
we will be searching for and then we are
interested in searching out the
the result vector that is basically the
column from which we want the value
that's our salary column so let's select
this
and that completes our lookup function
so now if you hit on
enter it shows that for this employee
where the name is hunk saunders the
salary
is 5400 now you can test it
by basically giving some other name
so for example if i replace this with
say fred stone
and that basically shows me the value
for fredstone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is hank
saunders
and that shows me the salary so that's a
simple
example of lookup which allows you to
search by selecting a range of columns
rather than
having the left most column which has to
be referenced
similarly we have one more question find
the employee id
of this particular email id
so we need to again use our lookup
function so we'll say
lookup now what are we interested in we
will search based on this email address
so i will select this
then i need to give that based on
email address we are searching the
employee id so email address is in this
column so let's select this range
and then we are interested in employee
id so then
goes our result vector so select this
column
and that basically completes your
formula so close this bracket and hit on
enter so that basically
shows me the employee id for an employee
with this email address so this is how
you use
lookup now as i've explained earlier
you can be using the if error and
you can basically see how
your index match can be used now here is
an example of if
error so basically this shows how if
error helps
so say for example as i showed in your
sheet one
so check for employee james bond if the
value is not present
display not found and what are we doing
we are basically nesting
our vlookup inside if error
with a not found option which basically
says
if the value given in the cell
h is not found then basically
it will display not found
so here you also notice that the range
which has been given
has been selected that is b1 to
c21 now we could have used a named range
which basically helps us in searching
for
multiple functions we are searching for
2 that is the column number 2 here that
is employee name
so check for employee james bond if the
value is not present or no
so we are basically just searching for
employee name
here and then give your 0 or 1.
so that's basically usage of your if
error which i have shown earlier
and the same thing can be applied for
your edge lookup
also now suppose you have been given
some
additional questions for example you
know
instead of using your vlookup or edge
lookup or lookup
examples what we have seen say for
example
you are asked to find the salary of
peter
daniels now we already know how to find
that
using vlookup right so for example we
want to find out the salary for this
employee name
which is peter daniels i can use a
vlookup
however sometimes we may also want to
use a
index match an index match is also one
useful
function to do that so we can basically
search based on that so we have to
define the range
of data we have to then say what do we
want to match
so that's basically an employee name and
then we are
interested in finding out say for
example
based on the range of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are
then giving a range and doing it how do
we do that so for
example here i can use a
function which is called index and if
you see here it says returns a value or
reference
of the cell at the
intersection of a particular row and
column
in a given range so this is where index
function can be useful
now we can start with this function it
says it needs an
array that's nothing but a range so we
can basically select all our data
so i can say a1 all the way to
e21 so that basically is my range
now i would want to find the salary
of this employee name which is peter
daniels
so i can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to
basically give it correctly so we need
to say
match now how does this match function
work
so we need to basically match for a
value
so for example we will select whatever
employee name is given here
so that's peter daniels now that's
basically what we would want to match
now where do we want to match this so we
want to match
in the column b which has employee
names so we can give a range which is b1
to be 21 so that's basically
within the employee names we are looking
for a
match which is given here
that's in h6 and we want to do a match
so we want to do a exact match so let's
do a comma zero
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column
so let's basically give the column
number here
and then just close this bracket
so that basically completes your
function
and just hit on enter so that shows me
the salary of peter daniels
right so this is an easy way when you
can use the
index function remember first you give
the range
and then you need to give your matching
condition so when you say
match i would take the value whatever is
given in this cell
i will search in the range of values
which is employee names
i will find an exact match and what i'm
interested
in is finding the salary for peter
daniels
now similarly say for example you have
been given a question
find the employee id with salary 10 000
so you want to find out the employee id
wherever the salary is 10 000
so we are obviously looking for an exact
match now how do we do that
so we can start with our index function
and with an index function we need to
give a range
so for example i am interested in
finding out
say for example our range which is
a 1 2
e 21 so that's what i'm interested in
or you are actually interested in
searching based on say
your salary so you are interested in
searching the employee id
so maybe if i just do a 821 let's see
what happens here
now then i can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here
h 13 so i will do a match for this one
now i need to give a range
so let's basically give a range which
will be
we are interested in searching employee
id based on the salary
column so that's your e column so i will
say
e1 to e 21 that's what i'm interested in
searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match
so first let's close this one now
that's fine i mean we are interested in
finding out the employee id
based on the match which is within this
range
and then what we would want to do is
we would want to basically find the
employee id
employee id is in my column a
so what i can do is i can additionally
give a match here
and then i can say i'm interested in the
finding out the value for employee id
and that basically needs a range
so the range here will be just the the
column headings
so we will give a1 all the way
to e 1 so that's the range
in which we would want to search and we
would want to
find a match for employee id we want an
exact match
so let's close this one and that
basically closes my match and we need to
close our index function
so now that shows me employee id where
the salary
is 10 000. so this is how
you can do your index matches where you
can give a range
then you can say what you need to match
within which particular column whether
it is an exact match or approximate
match
and then the column from where you are
interested in finding out the value
so same thing we did here we basically
gave a complete range
and if you closely see we were only
interested in finding out the employee
id so here
i give a range a1 to 821 which is
basically
this particular column so that's where
we are interested in finding out
match basically will give your lookup
value so that's h13
then we gave a range which is salary
that's what we are interested in
and then we said when we are doing a
match we are only interested in finding
out the
employee id which is in a range of
column names
and then doing an exact match so this is
how you can use
index match instead of lookup which can
also give you
some exceptions and searching for
specific columns or specific rows
now if error we have already discussed
where you
nest your vlookup or h lookup inside it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions
hlookup vlookup lookup or index match to
search for
data some function like this which shows
up
xln dot x lookup and then you're trying
to search for something so don't be
uh surprised with that so xln
is basically a prefix added to functions
that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using
you have excel 2013 and say your friend
has a new version of excel say office
365
or excel 2016 and basically he uses your
new
cool function and sends the file to you
so that's where
you will have this xln prefix as i'm
showing up here
so for example what is the job title of
xavier power
is what you would want to search and
here the function which shows up
excel and x lookup and then you are
searching so this is basically
something which is the function now if i
just select
what it has selected here and if i hit
on enter
it shows that this does not work in my
excel here
and that's because of the version but
what i can do is i can fix this by
removing
this details here
and that basically shows lookup we are
searching for
job title based on employee name which
is in this field
h6 and then we need to give a range
so we need to give a range of names
employee name
and then basically the job title
range which is basically the job title
so now if i just hit on enter
it gives me the value so it's as simple
as that
similarly here what is the employee id
of the person
with this email we have already looked
at the lookup function
so if it shows your xlnx lookup all you
need to do is remove this
and then keep the lookup function
searching for the value
based on the range of values and then
searching for a value within a range of
values so just hit on enter and that
gives you the value
and same thing goes for this job title
so what is the job title and salary of
employee name
so we have this function now what i can
do is
here i am interested in finding out the
value for this particular function
how do i fix this i can basically select
this
and then just do a lookup based on the
values
and it basically says you can't change
part of an array so we can fix this now
what we need to do
is we need to basically search based on
this particular value so we will
basically say i want to do a lookup
now lookup should be based on employee
name
whatever name is given here then you
need to
find the job title in salary so for job
title
i want to find based on employee name
so i will give a range
and then basically i will say i'm
interested in finding out the job title
so i will give a different range
and then basically close this so that
basically shows
now this is basically because of the
function which we have here so basically
to fix this
what we will have to do is we will have
to delete all the
columns here which were selected such as
employee name job title and salary
because that was giving you
an error you cannot delete a part of an
array
now what we want to do is we want to
find the job title
and salary based on the employee name
so we can do that using lookup as we
have done earlier
so we will use a lookup function now
what we are interested in finding out
is the job title based on employee name
so we can select this cell which does
not have any value
then we need to basically say from which
range or based on what you want to
search
so we want to search based on employee
name and we want to find out the job
title
so we can basically give a range of
values
and then we will be interested in
finding out the job title
so let's select the job title range and
that basically completes our lookup
so let's close this and hit on enter now
it says obviously
error because this does not have any
value
we will fix that by giving in a value
here
same thing we can do for salary so for
example i can just drag and drop it here
and in this one instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary
so let's see what is the range we give
so the range should be employee name
so we will basically select employee
name
as the range and then
we are interested in finding out
the salary so we will select this
particular range
and what we are interested in finding
out is basically
employee name or we are interested in
finding out based on employee name
so let's select this particular column
and then hit on enter so both of these
are any values now
just feed in an employee name so we will
say for example eduardo
and that basically gives me the job
title
and salary so that's how you can fix
your
excel fn error so same thing goes here
so it shows you xln is what you would
want to search
might be if you don't find something you
would want to
push in name not found so first is we
will have to fix this
part so we will have to remove this
because that's not supported in my excel
and then i have lookup i am searching
based on h24
which is basically employee id you are
giving a range which is a2 to 821
because we would want to find name
not found for a particular employee id
so i'm giving a range which is a2 to 821
i'm trying to search for the name which
is from b2 to b21
and then i'm giving name not found so
say for example we can do this lookup
but then
with lookup you don't have this direct
option
what we can do is we can use if
error if
error and then basically try to search
so that gives your lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this
we can obviously go for vlookup and fix
this so
here we are searching for a particular
range
and then let's search for this value and
basically to fix this what i did was i
just use a vlookup so we know that
employee id
121 does not exist so i'm just using if
error
i'm doing a vlookup where i'm searching
for the value given
in h 19 and then
i'm saying that i would want to search
from a range which is basically b1 to
c21 that is in
employee name and say email address
for example and we would want to
basically search for
name not found so we can instead of
giving
b21 or b1 to c21 we can restrict it to
just b1 to b21
we are searching in column two we are
searching for exact value and if it does
not find
then it says name not found and that's
how
we do it so we can always replace and
fix this
excel fn errors if
you are using
uh some spreadsheet which was or excel
which was sent
by someone else who is using a different
version
so in this way we can use your tickle
different
look up functions take care of your
errors
use a index match welcome to this
tutorial
on microsoft excel let's quickly see
some more examples of doing data
analysis
using excel and for that we can
use some inbuilt add-ins which can be
added to our excel sheet so for example
if you would want to do a descriptive
analytics or descriptive analysis on
your data
say for example getting your descriptive
statistics
such as your mean median mode and so on
so we can do that
and we can use excel for it so for
example you can
if you are given some data say i have
temperature
price of ice cream units sold and i
would want to have descriptive
statistics on this
what i can do is i can click on file and
here in file you can click on options
and within options click on add-ins now
within add-ins you have
excel add-ins which is selected here
so click on say go for example and that
shows
what add-ins are available and you can
choose which ones are you interested in
so for example i have chosen
analysis tool pack and solver
add-in and click on ok now that
basically
should add more options to your excel so
if you click on data
so here you see data analysis and
solver and this is what we would want to
use to get
our descriptive statistics for these
three columns
so for example let's say temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis
and here it says what are you interested
in
there is a two factor with replication
you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histogram so let's click on
descriptive statistics
click on ok now this one basically asks
your input range so while your cursor is
blinking
here also it is said
grouped by so let's give it a range so
for example i will say
say temperature now if i do this
and i have selected the heading just
look at that
and now you need an output range so
let's just select this
and then you can have your cursor
blinking here
let's select save fields here
and this is where i would want the
output now it also said what
options do you want so it has output
range
we can then select summary statistics
confidence level
so i will say summary statistics is what
i'm interested in say okay
and this says input input range contains
non-numeric data now why is that because
we
chose temperature the heading also so
click on ok
and here we will alter the range
so this one is our range should be
only the values numeric values on which
we would want the descriptive statistics
we have output range already selected we
have summary statistics
and now you can click on ok
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here i could basically
given a value for this so i can say
temperature
and that's my descriptive statistics for
temperature
might be i can just do some formatting
and that's it so that gives me
descriptive statistics for the values
here
now similarly we can do it for price of
ice cream
so what we need is we need to basically
go for data data analysis
descriptive statistics say okay
now you need to give a range so here
i will change my range to these values
output range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on ok
and this says output range will
overwrite existing data
press ok to overwrite data in range i
will say
cancel no that's not what we want to do
we need to give a new range
so let's select our new range
which is here and now click on ok
so now we get the values which is for
your
price of ice cream so again we can
basically
select this and say price of
ice cream and we got
our descriptive statistics for price of
ice cream
and like we did earlier i can select
this
i can basically do a merge and center
and that gives me
descriptive statistics for price of ice
cream
so we could also basically change this
now i can go into data and i can go
into data analysis descriptive
statistics
so we know that we had selected this b2
to b8 and this one which is
h6 to h19 we would want to shift
it might be two columns up so might be i
can just say h5
and i can manually change it to at 17
and let's say okay and
we will basically get this and i can get
rid of this
so i can have it in the same range
so similarly so this one will have to be
renamed
and i can basically say price of
ice cream and that's basically my
descriptive statistics
for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units
sold so we would want to have this now
let's see
we can click on data we can click on
data analysis
descriptive statistics so we need to
give the range correctly so this time
our range changes to units sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if we were selecting the
heading so let's do it in this way so in
my
range in my range
let me empty this i can basically select
this
which we know has non-numeric data in
the first row
say for example i'll say labels in first
row i'm interested in summary
statistics and this range will now have
to be changed
from h to basically
something like j so let's say
j and let's select these values
so that should take care of things and
now you see
you have your units sold you did not
have to manually rename
it and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can
simply perform analysis using data
analysis here
you can basically get your descriptive
statistics for your columns
and then you can do whatever needed
formatting
you need to basically make your data
look in a good way
now let's look at one more example of
data analysis
where we may want to look at the
frequency of values or
frequency of values occurring in a range
of values
so for example if you have been given
temperatures
you have been given some pins where you
would want to
identify how many values fall into the
range of 0
to 20 20 to 30 30 to 40
40 to 50 and the easiest way to do that
would be creating histogram now
histogram is usually used for data
analysis
where you would want to look at
different variables or say
features for example temperature is one
such feature
might be there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see
if the increase or decrease in
temperature affects the increase or
decrease in
sale of ice cream might be sale of ice
cream is a
is a response based on temperature so it
depends
so sometimes you may want to find a
relationship between two variables
whether they are positively or
negatively related
or you would want to do different kind
of analysis and in
certain cases we may want to first do
analysis on
one single variable look at the
frequency of values
might be also look at the defects and
for which we can use something like
pareto chart
so we can go for histogram and that
basically gives us the frequency of
values now how do we do that
so we have already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say ok
now i have already selected input range
so if you see here my input range is
temperature
which is also with the headings and
i have bin range which is basically
the range of values so for example i can
select this
and that's my bin range i am selecting
or the option labels because i'm using
the first
row which has the heading such as
temperature and bins
now we need to give a output range so
for example let's say
i would want my data here and that
becomes my output range
so you can have a sorted histogram or
basically a pareto chart
so if that's what you are interested in
looking at the frequencies
for your different ranges and here i am
also selecting chart
output because i would want to have a
visual histogram which gives us the
frequency
and it's as simple as this just click on
ok
and now you get your bins so it
basically tells you frequency of values
which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking
as a range of 0 to 20 so we have 0 to 20
that is 2
so we can basically say there is 120
here
with the 20 being the maximum value and
then there is one more 20
so that's your 0 to 20 then you have 20
to
30 which shows three values so might be
in that case i can say
26 is one thing
then i can say 30 that's the second one
and then basically i can look at 22
so basically this one does not select 20
as the lower range but it basically
selects 30 as the higher range
so i do see 20 to 30 there are three
entries
similarly we can see values for 40 and
50
and since we have selected pareto or
sorted histogram that shows in a
descending order
what is the highest frequency of
values within a particular range
so that shows me highest frequency is
five and then you have three
and three and then 2. so this is how
we can create a histogram and we can
perform analysis
on a single variable now
as discussed earlier as i said sometimes
we may be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold
and we may want to find out the
correlation between
one variable to another variable or we
would want to find out the
relationship between variables
are they linearly related are they
positively related
negatively related and so on and for
that
we can use the correlation of your data
analysis
add-in so for example you want to find
out correlation of temperature
and units sold and what we can do is
we can find out that using a formula so
for example if i
search for something like co
relation and let's search so there is a
function called correlation which we can
use
and we can use this to calculate the
correlation of
temperature and units sold so for
example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array
and a second array so we are interested
in finding out correlation of
temperature in units sold
so let's select the range of values for
temperature
and then i am interested in finding out
the correlation of temperature in units
sold
so let's select this and that basically
gives me a range of values
it gives me the correlation value which
is 0.2859
say ok and that's your value so
similarly
we can do it for temperature and price
ice cream
so let's go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in
you need to give a range of value so
here we are interested in temperature
and price of ice cream so let's select
temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of
ice cream let's select that let's close
our bracket
and here we have the correlation value
of temperature
and the price of ice cream similarly you
may be interested in finding out
temperature and units sold like what we
have done
earlier so we can do the same thing
based on function so this is same as
correlation of temperature in units sold
so i can get rid of this one
now how do i do it using the data
analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into data
we need to click on data analysis and
here
you have the option called correlation
let's select
this now that basically needs an input
range
so we need the range now i might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature
and price of ice cream and units sold so
i've selected
all the columns here we will say group
by columns obviously we need to select
labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading
now output range you can just give one
simple cell and that's where your data
will start from
or you can give a new workbook so click
on ok
and that basically gives you
that basically gives your correlation
of your different variables and what are
the values and we can
check these values based on the values
what we have here so we have basically
temperature
and price of ice cream
and that basically shows me 0.96149
you have temperature and units sold so
you have 0.2859
now you can also look at units sold and
say for example price of ice cream
you can look at these particular values
so if i would be interested in finding
out what
is the relationship between these
variables i can easily
find using correlation so i could be
basically writing in a formula here and
selecting
what are the cells so here we were
selecting
a2 and c
here we were selecting a and b
now might be i'm interested in price of
ice cream and units sold
and if that's what i'm interested in
then i will give a range of
b2 to b8 c2 to c8
and similarly you can get your analysis
or correlation
values so it's very simple in excel
and you can use either the data analysis
tab
and get your correlation or you can use
formulas
and do that now one more important part
of data analysis
is doing your sampling now sampling
could be periodic sampling or random
sampling so sometimes you may want to
look at a variable
and you may want to get some values
based on
periodic data that means might be
i'm interested in range of values i'm
interested in seeing a sample of values
for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if i go
for periodic sampling
so out of these values which i see here
might be i want to see say periodic
sampling that is
a frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or
i would go for random sampling so
basically randomly
i would want to pick up say three
temperature values now how do i do it
so for example here i have seven values
now if i go for periodic sampling
the sample or periodic sample value
which i need to give
has to be lesser than the total
input values so for example
we can do this let's go in here and
let's go for
data analysis so we can go for sampling
here click on ok
and that needs a range of values so we
will select
a2 to a8 now i could have selected
all the values for this one temperature
and in that case i can give labels which
is going to take care of the first
row now here we can go for
number of samples which we are
interested in or giving a period
so let's go for period and say for
example i have seven values
so what if i select five so for example
if i say
five that means i could just
get one value so basically when i'm
saying
five out of seven so that's just giving
me
out of five i want one value
so i can then just give an output range
so
here i can basically select this cell
i'll say okay and now you see it just
shows me
one value so out of the first range
that is i have said five it has given me
the fifth value
that's your periodic sampling so for
example
we want more values so let's reduce this
period to might be 2 which basically
gives me every second value so i can
basically
say for example 2 and say ok
and then say ok so that shows me
26 then you have 35
then you have 40 and then well this one
does not have any more value so that's
your periodic sampling
now if you go for random sampling that's
basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want
so go for data analysis go for sampling
i'll go for number of samples how many
you want
so for example out of seven values
randomly i want three values
and i can just give this say okay
and then we will do a cancel because we
need to change that
range so let's select this and say okay
and that gives me random three values
from this
values of temperature so we can use
excel
to do a simple sampling and we can
choose whether we would want to go for
periodic sampling
or random sampling let's continue
learning
excel and how excel can be used for data
analysis
now we have seen sampling histogram
correlation descriptive stats and now
also let's look at regression
now what is regression so when you talk
about statistical modeling regression
analysis is used to estimate the
relationship
between two or more variables and
basically we would want to look at two
or more variables
and basically a relationship of those
variables with the response
or the target right so for example if we
look at our data here we have
temperature
we have price of ice cream and then we
have units sold
and we can go ahead and make predictions
so for example when you look at
regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics
you have anova you have
different plots which we have here which
is x variable
x variable 2 and then you have normal
probability plot
now we have already seen how you can
have your
add-in that is data analysis which helps
you in doing
different kind of data analysis here
right now how do we do this
so we have our variables here which is
temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression
we need to understand which one of these
are independent variables which one of
these are
dependent variables right so when you
talk about your x
and that's your independent variable or
we can say predictor
or explanatory so when you talk about
your
independent variables or as we say
predictors
or explanatory variables these are the
factors that might influence
the dependent variable and when you talk
about dependent variable that's your
response or target
that's the main factor you're trying to
understand or predict
so we can plot a scatter plot to see
relationship between variables
if they are linearly related are they
positively related
negatively related and so on we can also
get values such as r square which is
coefficient of determination
regression line and then analyze
the relationship between variables so
here is one of the links of one of my
edit other videos where we are learning
on machine learning and also
on regression but that's
programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
excel
so basically we would want to use our
variables which is temperature
price of ice cream units sold and then
get these plots so what we can do is for
example
i can get rid of this and might be i can
just say
no borders and when it comes to these
plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal
using your data analysis add-in tool
so we have been given variables here now
as i said
when we talk about your regression
analysis
we need to understand whether we have
one variable
or we have multiple variables right
so you might have heard of univariate
analysis bivariate analysis and so on
well here we are focusing more on
using excel to do our regression
analysis
so i will not go deeper into regression
topics
but certain things as basics should be
known
that when we talk about regression
analysis what does it do
it helps you understand how the
dependent variable
changes when one
or more independent variables vary
and it basically allows us to
mathematically determine which of those
variables
really has an impact so technically
when we talk about regression analysis
model that is based on the sum of
squares
which is basically a mathematical way to
find the
dispersion of data points so
mainly the goal of the model is to get
the smallest possible sum of squares
and draw a line that comes closest to
the data
so that's what we mean by our regression
line
or basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points
fall on a regression line if there are
residuals that is points which do not
fall
on the regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about statistics
we differentiate between a simple and
multiple linear regression
so you have something called a simple
linear regression
models which basically gives you the
relationship between dependent variable
and one independent variable using a
linear function
and if you use two or more variables
that is explanatory
variables to predict the dependent
variable we are actually dealing with
multiple linear regression so if the
dependent variable
is modeled as a non-linear function
because the data relationships do not
follow a straight line
we have to use non-linear regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this
might be based on temperature price of
ice cream
we would want to find out how many units
were sold
now what we can do is we can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot
which is quite easy in excel so if you
have been given variables what you can
do is you can click on insert
you can then choose the kind of plots
which you want and here you have
insert scatter plot so we can choose
this and you can choose the first option
so that gives you a blank
layout and what you can do is now you
need to select data
so for example let's click on select
data and then
you can say add so what we would want
is we can give a name so we want x
values
and we want our y values right
so when you talk about y that's your
dependent variable
or your response or target so that is in
our case units sold
and x values are one set
of features or variables or multiple
variables so here
i can click on this series x values and
then i can
select this now in y values what i can
do is
i can select these and then i can just
say okay
so that shows me that it would be giving
me a
regression scatter plot now let's say
okay and we have some points plotted
here now
if you would want to see the impact of
one individual variable
such as temperature or price of ice
cream
you could as well do that now what you
can also do
is you can add more meaning to this by
giving in a title or you can also go
into quick layout
and you have various options here so you
see it gives you
what is the access title what is the
series
and i would prefer to use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your
r square and that gives you your y and
x that is your coefficients so
let's select this one and then we have
some values which we can use to compare
this also shows me the regression line
and you can keep this for reference if
you would want you can change
the chart title to something else a
scatter plot
of dependent
was independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning
and we can get rid of this one so we
have series and we can say what are
these points if you would want to
add in legend if you would want to do
that or i can just get rid of this
and i will keep these values here
which we will see when we do a data
analysis we can
always compare these values so here
i have created a simple scatter plot
and then i can look at dependent ways
independent variables or
i could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my
x-axis what is my y-axis
so basically you can here
say for example just say y and might be
here i will say x and we can
rename that later now how do we perform
data analysis
or get into regression right now what we
would want to do
is we would want to get
or we would want to do the regression
analysis to demonstrate the relationship
between
dependent on independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation
you might have known about it so it is
basically
y when you say y
equals you can say
bx plus a plus
c and this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression
where x is your independent variable
y is your dependent variable
your a is the y-intercept
which is expected mean value of y
when all x variables are equal to zero
so basically on a regression graph
that's the point where line crosses the
y axis
and that's your intercept when you talk
about
b that's basically your slope of
regression line
which is the rate of change for y
as x changes and then you also
have your constant right so that's your
uh sorry that's basically your random
error term
right which is basically the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value
so your linear equation always
has an error term because in real life
predictors are
obviously never perfectly precise
right now what we can do is we can also
reduce this
equation to y is b x
plus a and that's the equation of a line
we can look into this and the linear
equation
can be understood mathematically in this
way now how do we do it in
excel so what we can simply do is
[Music]
here let me yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one
and from these different options you can
choose regression so that's what we
would want to do
now we'll say okay now here you need to
give your input y
range so as i said you will have to
select
the dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here
and here we have your x and y
so y being your target
that's basically your unit sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to x either you can select
one variable
or multiple variables so i will select
temperature
price of ice cream and then since we
have chosen the headings we will go for
labels right now we can
always look at the confidence level we
can change that
so you can say whether you want it in a
new worksheet
or you can just say output range and i
will
probably just click here and select one
of the cell here
now we can also choose the other options
which we would want to see
as a part of this regression analysis so
basically we
have selected input y range which is
your dependent variable
you have selected x range which is your
independent variable
and if we are building a multi
regression model
then we have chosen temperature and
price of ice cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range
which is basically on this sheet and
then we can select the residuals
so that basically gives you your
residuals
now we can also get your line fit plots
which you were seeing earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots
and then basically just say okay
and let's say okay and that
basically gives you your regression
analysis output so we
basically have your summary output we
also have anova
we have our serial output that's from
the previous one
and basically we can get rid of this
that's not required
i can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics
we also have our plots so we can
basically look into these so we have our
normal
let's get rid of these let's get rid of
this
let's get rid of this and then
what we can do is since we had some
existing data
it has overwritten so let me get rid of
this and i'll repeat this step again
and let's say what if
yeah so now what we want to do is we
want to do a reaction analysis
so we go get into data we get into data
analysis
we choose regression we have already
chosen our
y range which is column c x range
multiple variables we have gone for
labels
output range which we would want to
select
a particular cell so let me select this
i am going for residuals line fit plots
normal probability plots
and say okay so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables
so here it shows me units sold and then
what are the predicted units sold and
here the variable is temperature
here the variable is price of ice cream
right so that's your one variable and
second variable
and then you also have your normal
probability plot
now to interpret this or to understand
what we have here where we look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
excel
it is performing all the calculations
automatically the interpretation
is something which we need to understand
so basically we are looking at
multiple r value here and we can
let's also fine tune this one
yeah we have our values here and if you
see
we have our r square now
we can then basically look at our
multiple r so what is your multiple r
that's your correlation coefficient
which basically measures the strength of
linear relationship
between two variables so
[Music]
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient
it can be any value between -1 and 1 and
its
absolute value indicates the
relationship
strength so the larger the absolute
value
the stronger the relationship so 1
basically means a strong positive
relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and 0 means no relationship
at all
now when you are looking at r square
that is the coefficient
of determination which is used as an
indicator
of the goodness of the fit so it
basically
shows how many points fall on the
regression line
so your r square value is basically
calculated from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared
deviations of the original data from the
mean now when we talk about
looking at the value of your r square so
it is
basically we can be seeing
that this is 0.450788
that's the value which i am talking
about so it basically means
45 of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words
45 percent of dependent variables that
is your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your x
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit
and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted r square it is the r square
adjusted
for the number of independent variables
in the model
so you would want to use this value
instead of r square
for multiple regression analysis
such as in our case now you also have
standard error
so that's basically goodness of fit
measure
that basically shows the precision of
your regression
analysis so the smaller the value the
more certain
you can be about your regression
equation so
when when we talk about your r square
that represents the percentage
of dependent variables variance that is
explained by the model
and standard error is basically an
absolute measure that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so
you will have to look back into
regression
statistics terminologies to basically
understand more of this
and if you're already from data science
background that then you already know
what i'm talking about
we are just seeing how excel easily
helps us
in doing these things now we can
also look at observations here which is
basically the number of observations in
our
model which is 7. now when we talk about
regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your anova
values here so we basically see df
you have ss ms f
and significance f now
to understand these so basically what we
are doing is
or what excel is doing is it splits the
sum of squares
into individual components that give
information
about the levels of variability within
your regression model
so when you talk about your df that's
basically the number of degrees of
freedom
associated with the source of variance
you have sum of squares that is your ss
so smaller the residual ss compared with
the
total ss the better your model fits the
data
right now when you talk about ms that's
your mean square
you have f is basically the f statistic
or you can say f test for the null
hypothesis
basically it is used to test the overall
significance of the model
and then you finally have your
significance f
which is the p value of f so
uh when we when we usually talk about
seeing simple linear regression
the in anova part is
not really used or it's rarely used
right but when we look at the
significance
f value that gives an idea of
how reliably or statistically
significant
our results are so if significance f
is less than 0.05
that's 5 percent our model is ok
if it is greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent
variables right now we can also look at
the output of coefficients and that's
what
we would want to look at so you
basically have your
intercept here so when you talk about
your intercept
temperature price of ice cream so we
know we are looking at our variables
and then we are also looking looking at
our
intercept which basically gives you
more details on your coefficients so the
the main important thing when we talk
about regression analysis
is basically your coefficients it
basically enables you to build a linear
regression equation
uh in the form of y equals bx plus a
which i explained earlier and then
basically we can
understand our regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output
which we are seeing here so that gives
you your
observations how many observations we
have
it shows what is the predicted units
sold
and then it also gives you your
residuals
so we can compare the estimated and
actual number of sold
umbrellas based on the observation so we
have 11.209 here
and if you compare that's basically 12
the second one is 15
and here it is 13.5 you have
and similarly you can compare all the
values of actual units sold
and what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these
and we will see if there is any
difference or no
right so obviously there will be
or there would be some difference
because independent variables are never
perfect predictors of your dependent
variables
and the residuals basically help us
in understanding how far the actual
values are
from the predicted values so
that's what we see here in the residual
section
so for example when we look at this one
which is 11.209
and the actual is 12 we see what is the
residual
and how far is the predicted value from
the
actual value so similarly we can also
look at the percentile values
so that gives you your probability
output and this is what we have in our
graphs so we have basically our
variables
we are looking at our variables and also
the units sold
and the relationship between them we can
basically
uh add in more details to this
particular plot and you also have
normal probability plot which is
basically getting
your values from your probability output
here so this is how you can perform a
simple regression analysis and now what
you can do
is you can as i said you can basically
be looking
at your scatter plot you can be looking
at your y
and x and your r square values right but
remember
what are the variables which you are
selecting and then
you can compare these with
basically the values what you see here
so remember here i've chosen my
both set of variables and you can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact
on the response or on the target
so it's pretty simple here you can
add more details to your scatter plot or
the plots what we have
created or some people prefer to do it
using
formulas so basically we have some
statistical functions that
can help you do linear regression
analysis such as
you have linus you have slope you have
intercept you have correlation and so on
so basically you can use these
particular functions
and what you will have to do is
you will have to basically go in for
a function if that's what you would want
to do
and then you can search for functions
and say for example i'll just say nest
and say go and here i have my function
so if i would want to really use this
one i can do that
what i will have to do is then select
the variable so if you just say okay
and that basically says your known y's
known x your constants your stats
and basically you can use the formula
also but we are not covering that here
might be in the later videos we can do
that so
just try out and perform some regression
analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that
so that basically gives you an easier
way
of performing regression analysis
using your data analysis add-in in excel
and that brings us to the end of this
video in data analytics with excel
i hope it was useful and informative if
you have any questions
then please feel free to put them in the
comments section thank you for watching
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here